there's no time
[Music]
[Music]
hey
it's us
here we are again yeah thank you very
much for the early super chat yeah jeffy
art jeffy art yep it's been up since 1
30 a.m and just got back from teaching
classes was like 1 30 a.m like eastern
standard time are you in a different
time zone
uh i'm so ready to rock also i love
jenny's new channels well thank you very
much i've been working very very hard on
those so i'm glad you guys are enjoying
them um and i'll remind you guys if you
haven't there's one called the scare
salon that's all horror and there's one
called crime and memorial which is all
true crime
so i just put up a video on scare salon
today uh where i picked my five favorite
horror movies from 1974 because i'm
doing my five favorite horror movies
every year since i was born so that's
the third one that i did and tomorrow
there's gonna be a video going up on
crime immemorial about three family
massacres so that should be exciting
yeah you all got three paranormal videos
three paranormal shows back to back this
week
well it seemed to be what everybody
wanted yeah
i mean everybody's like really into like
a haunting well that's the thing like we
started out when we first started out we
did a lot more paranormal stuff but i
feel like we covered a lot of the kind
of big ticket like paranormal cases
yeah after a while people they kind of
get a little samey because the stories
are very similar
so we got to watch it you know i mean i
think covering it
the way haunting covers it is a lot
better because we can kind of goof on it
or [ __ ] remember the way those shows
were you know just
yeah it's a good angle to come at it
from but you know i liked this idea too
and i can't remember like because i know
one of you guys uh
recommended it and i was like oh that's
a good idea now i will say that like i
said i've got a bunch and i'm kind of
like
i don't really want to i don't want to
feel bad if i don't get to all of them
because i figured well i'll just put
like write-ups about some of the more
famous ones
and if i don't get to all of them it's
not really that big of a deal so i'm
just going to like keep it sort of
casual yeah um because you know like i
said there's lists all over the internet
of like ooh world's most haunted bars
and pubs blah blah so i kind of wanted
to keep it more to like the us and maybe
the uk
um because if i was like the whole world
i was like there's no way i can wade
through all of this stuff and like pick
out all the things so i tended to go
around to like a bunch of different
lists and like pick out ones that
appeared on more than one because i
figured they were probably best known or
ones that had appeared on like different
paranormal shows and [ __ ] like that so
you know it should just be a fun
just a fun show grandpa shows up after
being gone for a long time what's up
graham
uh he says uh fyi steve is coming to my
place tomorrow to look at ham radio set
up and shoot some bang stick okay
well there you go all right there you go
that's good
um let me see
i got uh i got my headphones and my
microphone in to uh stream live on
twitch i have a twitch channel
and um
i just did a trial
run and i think four or five people came
in zach was one of them that came in
uh and um
i was playing uh right now i was just
kind of doing a warm-up game for um
laura croft uh
tomb raider uh legend
i'm gonna play legend i'm gonna play
anniversary and i'm gonna play
underworld that's that's a lot right
there
and maybe i might i might jump into uh
um [ __ ] what's the one where's the
[ __ ] you're in the in the um
anniversary fall out i'll follow i might
if i get sick of that i might might do
fall out
um i haven't done all the add-ons to
fall out
what is it fallout 3 or fallout 4 or
[ __ ] i don't remember what the names
are i just play them i don't really
remember their names that much
one has nuka world and everything and
all the
far harbor i'm in far harbor right now
so i might i might do some of that
and uh i also got uh some [ __ ] metal
gear
games that i might get into
but um
it's what's interesting about it is that
uh
it's got fewer people in the chats right
now
we only had five today
and uh i can like speak freely a little
bit more freely there you know what i
mean because there's no topic so
if you guys just want to ask questions
or talk talk about any subject i can i
can talk about it there not to worry
about [ __ ] you know
uh
getting unsubscribed or anything or
[ __ ] this channel up you know over
there we is a lot more secure there was
special forces guys i know that we're
[ __ ]
[ __ ] giving and receiving [ __ ]
secure information
secret information they were doing it
over live chats inside games because
nobody pays any attention in there
you know
you had to know who it was but it's like
sf guys talking about [ __ ] that was real
where they were really gonna go and
mission times and stuff it's they don't
need number stations anymore they'll
just pretend to be a gamer and go in
there and [ __ ]
drop hints and [ __ ] say secret [ __ ]
in the right way it's kind of like
encode decode
kind of like one-time pads anyway
but there's different ways to do it just
if you know the guy real well you can
get the message across and that's where
a lot of it was going on
uh
so in there we can talk about anything
[ __ ]
radios guns survival anything
slasher fred said i like the old video
games like for the atari or the old nes
yeah i like them too
as well but they're they're um
they were real hard to play uh that you
had your timing had to be perfect on a
lot of those i really liked more of the
stuff from the late 90s
up to like uh mid 2000s 2010 you know i
just didn't like i didn't i don't like
too much realism
you know like i liked uh i liked all the
um
all the uh
[ __ ] doom games
like doom two and three and then i'll
[ __ ]
uh
doom 64 and
even the old quake you know that was
good too
it was like a good
the graphics were still kind of artistic
some of this stuff is so realistic
there's not a lot of art in it
i mean that's true but
i don't know i guess like more recent
games like fallout and stuff like that i
mean that's not that recent but yeah i
mean that looks realistic but i think
that's super cool just because i admire
how
large and detailed it is yeah i mean
there is a motifs behind them but
there's something about you know
look at those [ __ ] ghosts from
pac-man
it was the first time i saw like a
[ __ ] kind of a detailed animated
image i was a kid you know and there's
something kind of iconic about that two
dimensional kawaii [ __ ]
character you know there's just
something kind of artistic about them
but you know
you don't want to limit yourself to that
you know
they're doing that in newer formats i
mean those newer versions of galaga and
stuff that look pretty cool you know
it's just you can update anything
yeah and i mean there's some to be said
there's something to be said sometimes
like minimalist artwork looks better so
like it just depends like what the
application is i guess and what your
taste is so
i'm just kind of like i like all kinds
of things doesn't really matter to me
there's one that you can get
for xbox one you can order it for like a
dollar it's called refund
it's good it's got relaxing music and
you're jumping around changing the
colors of the tops these little blocks
that [ __ ] rise or fall
and it's and it's just a running and
jumping first person game and it's real
artistic and simplistic with like
vaporwave [ __ ]
background music and it's the sun's
constantly going up slowly and coming
back down slowly and it's all happening
in a damn
80s [ __ ] mall like [ __ ] universe
where everything looks like it's [ __ ]
1989 you know
neon and [ __ ]
to [ __ ] pastel colors and stuff and
it's called refund now you can get it
like a dollar 1.99 and you never get
sick of it you just play it over and
over again
it's very funny to me how that whole the
whole 80s aesthetic is still so
widespread like nowadays which and it's
not exactly what the 80s looked like
like if you were there
but it's kind of like an improved
stylized version of it which is fine
with me you know name of my channel on
um
uh [ __ ] what's the name of it on
twitch is uh tom 13 o'clock it's all
lower case there's no apostrophes tom 13
o'clock on twitch
so you can you can find me there
you'll get notifications when i come on
live everybody jumped in
uh oracle said has anybody mentioned the
game stray yet
oh the only reason i heard about that
was because i think there was a video
and i haven't watched it yet i think you
saw it in my suggested thing where
jackson galaxy was playing it so
supposed to like a game about kitty cats
the kitty cat game i haven't seen it
i haven't really seen it either like i
said i just saw that jackson galaxy was
playing so apparently like it's big
thing
granthar said famous haunted bar in
detroit the two-way inn
i don't have that one i don't think but
i did see that on some of the lists i
think haunted by the ghost of colonel
what is that
pelagius palladius pilates
pilates
colonel pilates machine norris a civil
war veteran and the original owner
oracle said yeah whoever designed it
knows kitties
they'll see i'm i was kind of curious
about it like when i saw it come up on
jackson galaxy because he made a video
about it where he was playing it and i
usually and i watch some of his videos
sometimes so his stuff like comes out on
the suggestion but you know what i mean
danny rowling telling some uh dad jokes
what does a drunk bar go say to scare
you
brew
love the dad joke that's a dad joke well
yeah that's what i'm saying yeah
yeah the the thing about this like i
said the ones that i picked are just
random so i'm sorry if i didn't get one
that you're like excited about but
and then there were some that i didn't
do because we've already like mentioned
them elsewhere like i didn't do bobby
mackeys or anything like that because we
already did a whole show about that
because it was on a haunting and i
didn't talk about there's actually one
in st augustine
but i didn't i didn't want to talk about
that one because i'm pretty sure that we
did a show about ghosts of st augustine
i might have mentioned it on there i
just didn't want to like repeat stuff so
i just like picked stuff from other
places so you know so like i said i feel
bad if like some people are like what
about this place and what about that
place i mean you know i can't like
i can't like get every place you know
what i'm saying yeah there's millions of
them there's millions of them and the
thing about it too is that now that
there's all those paranormal shows
pretty much every bar and restaurant
in the world is that's old is talking
about how
uh haunted it is because they want
people to come there because they're
going to get like the tv show and they
get like all kind of publicity and the
thing about it is that like a lot of
these bars too which i'll get into in a
bit have um
they'll do they do ghost tours and they
do you know like lockdowns like they let
people stay in there overnight and [ __ ]
like that
um so you know it brings in a lot of
tourism
you know so
to make of that what you will i don't
know if they're just like making stuff
up usually you can't get away with it if
it's like a new place though obviously
but if it's like an old historical place
where like some creepy [ __ ] happened or
like a famous person stayed there or
something like that then then yeah you
could get away with it then but
other than that you can't just build a
bar and be like yo it's haunted
slasher friend said one of the movies i
have seen is the wizard i can't remember
that it stars fred savage about a young
boy has a talent for playing video games
so so he and his brother can go on a
road trip to universal studios yeah i
remember that i think i saw that a long
time ago because fred savage was like
pretty a little that was maybe before
the wonder years i feel like wouldn't it
i don't know never heard of maybe never
heard of either one of those uh wonder
years was a very very popular tv show in
the 1980s uh jeffy art says the blue
anchor pub in delray beach is not far
from me supposedly was transported here
form from great britain and is haunted
and camp guy said i was just looking at
pirates house restaurant in savannah
georgia history back to the 1750s
pirates used to hang out there i've got
a couple i don't have either one of
those but i do have some other ones like
where pirates hung out and stuff
alien from la oh my god that was on um
mystery science theater
you know alien from la that one with uh
what's her face kathy ireland kathy
ireland and her and her super squeaky
voice
that was the one yeah she falls like
through a hole in the earth like looking
for archaeolog
archaeologist dad
and there's like a whole
uh kind of australian
mad maxian kind of society under there
do you know what i mean so she kind of
squeaks her way through there it's like
it's a bad bad movie but it's it's
pretty entertaining though i think at
least the mystery science theater
episode is
danny rowling said too bad the pub used
in the film an american werewolf in
london
isn't haunted because that would be sick
if it were yeah now
i don't remember was that a real pup
it's called the slaughtered lamb right
was that a real pub or was that
i mean because that's just a sign they
bought i mean that totally sounds like
something they would name a pub over
there but you know what i mean
i mean most of the pubs over there don't
have like real exciting names they're
usually like the king's head or
something like that but
you know or there's a couple on here and
one called like the red lion and that
kind of stuff but some of them have like
pretty weird names
pretty weird names um
yeah xc
oh
yeah featuring kathy ireland in a bikini
yeah they were trying to like make her
like she was
a geek at the beginning like they put
big glasses on her and it was clear that
it's like yeah she's not ugly so stop
doing that i remember that that sounds
vaguely
we i might have showed you the mystery
science theater you took us basically a
supermodel and put glasses on her and
then she's ugly now yeah i don't really
understand that's that's hollywood ugly
yeah
yeah
yeah it's like let's pull her hair back
in a ponytail put glasses on her she's
like there you go ugly so then we'll
like her yeah and then she just and but
like i said she has that voice
and but i don't think that's really her
voice maybe they made her sound like
squeakier than normal because she's like
she's super sweet she's super squeaky
[Laughter]
all right so uh wait do we have anything
else to
talk about before we get into
the haunted stuff or you want to talk
about some haunted no
that's about it we can get into it and
there we have enough people there just
let me plug my channel again i'm at um
tom 13 o'clock on twitch
no all lowercase there's no apostrophe
yeah yeah okay
um danny rowling said it's a real pub
the one from uh american whirlwind
london but i don't know what it's called
there's videos on youtube of the filming
locations and that pub is in some videos
okay yeah like it's not called that i'm
sure but
i mean i think i saw a t-shirt the other
day that had that sign on it and i was
like i kind of wanted it
i kind of wanted it
um yeah they're talking about alien from
la i mean
that's honestly that's one of my
favorite um mystery science theater
episodes mostly because
the song that they do like not during
one of the movie segments but during one
of the host segments they do that song
called my wild irish ireland and that's
one of the funniest [ __ ] songs that
they ever did i [ __ ] crack up every
single time like it's an irish reel but
the but the words are all about kathy
ireland and how he wants to make out
with her it's like super super funny yep
i picked up a couple more
just by plugging see thank you very much
for uh
joining me on twitch
uh xanada says lords of acid was a good
band just out of nowhere yeah
yeah they're not still around are they
uh probably not i doubt it because that
was a long time ago they had good album
covers
that's all these little devil girls on
there yeah
they still play them at the club every
now and then
speaking of haunted bars like i don't
really think um
none of the bars we hang out at are
haunted not that i know of unfortunately
there is one i don't know if it's still
there as of now
but downtown orlando there is like a
halloween
bar or like a you know what i mean what
the [ __ ] is the name of that place
i can't remember what it is but it's
super super cool looking they even have
like a like a vip room in the back
that's all like um that looks like a
room from the addams family house like
it's all like adam's family stuff it's
like really really cool
but
i don't know it it's just it's real
awesome looking but i don't remember
what it's called i think it's on church
street
but i don't think it's haunted though
it's just like halloween themed you know
um but yeah so anything else you'd like
to you're all right yeah i'm ready you
sure yeah okay i'm just saying you seem
kind of like
oh nothing just i don't have anything to
say about that
so no big deal just ready to go all
right let's get into it so let's talk
about some stuff and then you can
chime in whenever you want to like i
said i don't want to i don't feel any
particular pressure to get all of these
in
i just wanted to have
you know an array of ones to talk about
so we can like dip in and out of them
like at any point okay
so these are not in any particular order
or anything like that other than most of
the american ones i think are first and
then like it goes into the uk ones just
because that was easier for me to keep
them categorized that way i guess
so the first one let's talk about
is shaker's
cigar bar
and that is in milwaukee wisconsin
and it's in uh the third ward which i
guess is a historic uh area i've never
actually been to milwaukee so maybe
people that have been there can tell me
now the building was built in 1894
and before it was built it was actually
had it was a good old native american
burial ground apparently like it really
was it wasn't just like a [ __ ] thing
where they said that
so i guess it was a native american
burial ground so they put the building
there in 1894. now what it was
originally built as
was the schlitz brewery
the cooperage house now cooperage that's
building the the barrels right i'm
pretty sure i don't know
what why did i why do i know that like i
kind of i kind of feel like i maybe came
across that term
when i was reading something and i'm
like what's that and like looked it up
i'm pretty sure it's like making barrels
for like aging yeah probably i know i
must have i think i looked it up like
when i was doing like a true
crime jobs that no longer exist that's
what i mean that's why i didn't look it
up i'm like what exactly is that
no matter how important you think you
are in your job you know the chances are
60 years from now your job will not
exist and nobody will even know what
that job was
yeah barrel making okay so i did it
right i just can't remember like how i
came by that bit of information but i
specifically remember looking that up
once because but i don't remember what
context because i was like what is that
what is that job so i had to like look
at it but yeah it's barrel making so
that's what the building was originally
built for
it was uh to make barrels for the
schlitz brewery
so it was that like for a few decades i
guess and then like you know different
owners like took it over but then in
1922 the building was what nothing what
what's matter no there's [ __ ] things
don't worry about what i'm doing well
because you're well you're over there
you're over there going what the [ __ ]
what the [ __ ]
it's like really it's really my [ __ ] it
was on snap it's really distraught my
butt my
pocket was on a snap oh [ __ ] man
that's all
oh well i don't know yeah no no i don't
know just i i thought that was i thought
that was something like to do with what
i said and you're just over there yeah i
don't think he realizes like how
distracting he is over there like moving
around and mumbling and [ __ ] like that
my [ __ ] pockets weren't snapped look
[ __ ] your pocket [ __ ] man granthar says
schlitz beer hangover assured i wouldn't
know because i don't think i've ever
drunk a schlitz beer in my whole entire
yeah good morning
well yeah that's what i figured i mean
it's all piss water beer
yeah yeah that wasn't laverne and
shirley beer no that was shots
right i don't know s-h-o-s-c-h-o-t-z
like that
all those big fake german sounding
companies in the united states they were
all giant industrial beer factories
that just churned out [ __ ] piss water
you can make lots of it quickly and you
could
they could they could get it all across
the united states uh in lickety-split
times
it was a marvel modern marvel that these
places could too bad it just tasted
terrible they were like well better than
nothing i guess it got you drunk
that's what i'm saying it's like that's
probably why it sold because people like
well it tastes like ass but you know
gotcha it does the job and it didn't
cost anything right you could take just
a small amount of components
and make
like a
not even a lager really
but you could get it anywhere in record
time in the united states big country
you know and it would be refrigerated
even this is going back to the early
[ __ ] 30s 40s
you know and uh
you could get it and it would only it
wouldn't cause it was after prohibition
though and you can get it and it didn't
cost anything
and that and it rode like that all
throughout the [ __ ]
70s 80s wasn't until the 90s that you
started to see micro breweries come in
that actually that we actually got
good beer yeah and it was kind of going
back to the way beer was before the
industrial era
europeans have a [ __ ]
hard time understanding america they
look at our chocolate and our beer and
they think man that's what they you
don't understand that sucks you don't
understand that it was done at a soviet
level they they made seas of that oceans
of that and delivered it over a vast
area and it didn't cost anything so it
won
i mean but yeah but i mean quality is
going to suffer quality
sure
but it
but it was good enough it was good
enough yeah it did put a lot of your
local breweries out of business yeah
okay we had local breweries like in
europe some of them survived some of
them became big
yindling is a was a local brewery that
is still survived and it's big now
yingling is really good one of the few
beers that i actually
will order like if that's you know and
then sam adams came and it's okay and
then they had special
seasonal beers and
high-end beers and you had a choice
there it wasn't just one beer they'd say
they had 50 different ones you know and
even had little breweries you could go
to and drink out of it
um
so we had that [ __ ] it's just that
that's not what dominated the market
what dominated the market was piss water
bud but
yeah anheuser-busch
[Laughter]
[ __ ] like that schlitz
yeah yeah and then he started can't say
[ __ ] that we're gonna make malt liquor
which was like beer but it was thicker
and sweeter it's actually good it's
pretty good
oh i mean you can't get [ __ ] you get
fat you can get drunk off of it yeah it
was cheap but it tasted better than piss
water
the thing is is that black people picked
up on it they did it was good all right
well back in those days the white people
they wouldn't drink anything black
people don't wouldn't drink that
you know but i'd go buy it my friends
would be like man you're drinking that
malt liquor i said yeah did you get mad
dog 2020
[ __ ] what was it called 45
cold 45 [ __ ] right but they'd look
down you my friend my white friends will
look down on you like they don't drink
that [ __ ]
and they hear drink bud like man this is
[ __ ] worse
it was you know of course [ __ ] malt
liquor wasn't as good it was thicker and
it was sweeter
it was kind of like a like a german
viton
or white beer you know bites and beers
like that uh whites and when i was
drinking advice i was like man it's kind
of like [ __ ] motlick
[Laughter]
but um
i imagine the germans get pissed don't
you ever call our vikings [ __ ] malt
liquor but it's kind of like that
but uh
don't drink any of that [ __ ] you'll get
fat don't forget that heartbreak is the
way to go grandpa said old polish men
drink schlitz beer with their head
cheese and onion sandwiches
he said the worst thing about schlitz is
the nasty runs the next morning burning
ring of fire stuff schlitz is like i
said i've never explored i'm not a real
big um beer person
like i said if there's
if i ha if i'm at a place that doesn't
really have liquor and it's like kind of
all they'll have all they have is beer
then i'll usually get yingling or
i'll get something like a coffee porter
or you know something like that yeah
it's
american piss water beer is supposed to
be lager
it's not though okay
they're really stretching it
you know what i mean
you could take a small you know for for
for what would for for the amount of
ingredients that would make one decent
lager you could make five [ __ ] piss
water cans
and really reduce the price
and still get [ __ ] up on them the
alcohol content was pretty high you know
so the price went way down you just sell
a lot of it those companies made a lot
of money it was just survival of the
fittest
economics it's the same with hershey's
hershey's chocolate europeans have
turned her nose up on hershey's
hershey's chocolate is a hershey's
chocolate it's not
i mean hershey's is acceptable it's just
okay it's not the best chocolate but
it'll do but it was mass-produced
it was mass-produced right yeah yeah and
the germans wanted to say well we did
you y'all didn't invent chocolate all
right chocolate is mexican okay it came
from it came from mexico
uh but they were drinking it as a drink
and mixing it with human blood during
sacrifices only macho [ __ ]
drink [ __ ] with chili
chocolate and human blood [ __ ] from
sacrifices now see they should make that
candy bar make that candy bar
[ __ ]
that's what that's cause you know how
well a lot of like um you know artisan
chocolate companies started doing like
the chocolate and chili and all that
kind of stuff but as far as i know none
of them have human blood in there none
of them have gone that far but you never
know maybe some of them will yeah they
were [ __ ] they were real men down
there man [ __ ] your ass is going to
give up on the top of that temple you're
going to hate this
you're going to play back the blood that
god damn it and we're going to eat
protein tonight i don't know but that's
how that [ __ ] was man chocolate with
chili is good dana said mexicans still
eat chocolate chili yeah yeah yeah and
actually um that's kind of like spread
here too because i kind of feel like
people well people started putting like
chili powder like chili in there uh like
hot chocolate and all that kind of stuff
yeah but america has a lot of good
chocolate some of it you can buy in
stores some of you you can buy from a
[ __ ] candy maker they have candy
makers in certain places i don't mind
ghirardelli actually yeah that's out in
san francisco yeah but not i'm [ __ ]
i've been into damn confectioners man
[ __ ] bought a damn
an american reese's or an american
peanut butter cup the size of a [ __ ]
apple with just mouth-watering
chocolates like five different versions
of the chocolate
different versions of the [ __ ] peanut
butter filling with or without jet jelly
we call it jam or you guys gotta call it
jab we call jet it's just beautiful you
just you then you bite it it was like
five or six bucks for one of them and
you get about halfway through it you're
like oh i can't eat anymore the richness
just like you just wrap it up as a
zeitgeist next week you know just that's
how good they were though they were just
intense well like i said any any place
that makes stuff from scratch i told you
there's like a really famous um
chocolate shop like a confectionary shop
in st augustine that's been there
forever yeah um and they make everything
in-house and it's a tiny place yeah but
they make everything in-house and they
have like a huge like array of different
flavors mostly fudge but they make other
things too like you know chocolate
covered espresso beans and whatnot but
you can go in there and get like a half
pound of like mint fudge or maple or
like they have all different flavors and
they're all like delicious
uh the american hershey bar hershey
chocolate was a was a was was a miracle
in its era in his time
for
the ingredients basically for the amount
of cocoa beans that you maybe would make
one chocolate bar in germany you could
make 10 of those [ __ ] hershey bars
and get that price down to like a nickel
or maybe a penny
and all of a sudden poor people can now
afford chocolate and it was decent if
you realize how cheap that was
versus
yeah it's not bad at all yeah i mean
yeah like danny danny rowling pointed
out that hershey's chocolate tastes like
puke some say yeah some europeans think
it has like a vomiting taste which is
supposed to which it does because the
milk that they use is a little bit
spoiled like a little bit sour
so i can see that but we grew up on it
so i've had like way better chocolate
obviously like in europe and here or two
but it's fine like hershey's just fine
what mattered was the price and the
volume how much could be made they could
make lots of it quickly and the little
sour weird taste to it that it has
they noticed that when it happened they
could have corrected it but they decided
not to because it it had a different
signature it made it distinctive made it
distinctive yeah this isn't this isn't
this isn't european chocolate this is
hershey's chocolate so that's the way it
should taste
yeah i mean it was a deliberate i mean
we saw like a whole like that uh food
that built america show they did like a
whole episode about hershey's and they
were selling that hershey's chocolate to
other companies and they were using it
in the candy bars
and that little weird kind of flavor
americans grew up with it we expect it
if you you taste another chocolate bar
and it doesn't quite taste the same to
us
i mean it's good but it just didn't
price it doesn't taste like hershey's
chocolate yeah i mean it is whether you
like it or not it is a very
distinctive sour taste almost like
yogurt or cheese or or something
it's just kind of a like cheesecake a
little bit you know the cheesecake kind
of has a sourness to it with sweet it's
like that doesn't taste like vomit
that's going too far
but i know what you're talking about it
has a kind of a slight sour well if you
if you didn't grow up with that taste
then it might very well taste like vodka
but it's not it's not what it is
sour milk yeah that's why xanada said um
i love hershey's cookies and cream bars
yeah i agree those are good yeah it says
uh you can't beat white chocolate thank
you yeah i know that white chocolate is
very divisive i [ __ ] love white
chocolate it's not really chocolate but
it's good no i know and i know
somebody's got to bring that up every
time everybody knows it's not really
chocolate but um white chocolate peanut
butter cups i know oh my god white
chocolate peanut butter cups are so good
and honestly like i said i think i've
mentioned this before but every easter
when i was a little kid i was the weirdo
that always asks for a white chocolate
bunny instead of a chocolate chocolate
but i like regular chocolate too but
there's white chocolate i mean [ __ ] man
i'll eat zero bars all day long i'm
coming off my soapbox i don't i don't
need to defend food anymore
well not in defending anymore i can't
believe i got i didn't even get one
paragraph
before we already got into food
it was because we started talking about
schlitz and then like i bring culture to
these people
i break culture well gosh thank you so
much thank you thank you
[Laughter]
what would we do without tom to like
tell us everything
oh my god
danny rowling said uh what would you
rather a variety of hershey bars or a
whitman sampler
probably a whip
even though there are some ones in there
like i don't like the ones with the
fruity [ __ ] in the middle
but other than that like the whitman
sampler is pretty good i like the
coconut ones and the ones with like you
know peanuts and all that i said [ __ ] it
i even got to where i like the creams
and the [ __ ] gels
see i don't i'll eat all the other ones
i like the caramels i like the coconut i
like the nuts i like all that stuff but
the stuff with the fruity [ __ ] in the
middle yeah i'll the strawberry one is
okay like i'll eat it if i have to but i
like a ball i don't like the gel stuff
in the middle the gel one was okay you
gotta dive head first and not you can't
fight it you have to accept it for what
it is see that's the you got to go you
just got to lean into it you go yeah
that's what it is it's a gel that green
jelly
with the little bottom that little
bottom yeah nougat thing and then the
chocolate i don't hate it but it's like
it's weird somebody must have thought
that [ __ ] up in the 30s or something you
wouldn't do that is it kind of like a
maraschino cherry is that what they're
going for no it was green well i know
that but some like maraschino cherry
kind of things are green too like or
that flavor maybe that color
it makes no sense it makes no sense but
i got to where i just didn't even find
it anymore i was like yeah okay i kind
of feel like nowadays in this day and
age when everything is kind of
customized and specialized and bespoke i
feel like the whitman should have a box
that's just like no [ __ ] creams
or gels in it they got a box that's
nothing but creams i've bought them
before that's what i'm saying but just
but the fact that they have that yeah
i mean what kind of war crime is that if
okay so if they have the ones with like
the creams and the gels exclusively yeah
then they should conversely have one
that doesn't have any of that in it
that's what i'm saying some of them just
have caramels and peanuts and [ __ ] and
wouldn't it be hilarious if they just
called it no [ __ ] creams but
they're just a lot more expensive
well yeah because that's the good [ __ ]
on valentine's day you can get the one
that's just all creams and you get like
the day after valentine's day that's if
you that's if you don't still be there
that's if you don't love your girlfriend
that's that's the one
now listen what i'm saying
you go day after valentine's day and
then the ones that are all creams will
still be there and that [ __ ] will be
1.99
and i'd go in there and get like [ __ ]
so the people who like the cream ones
are just kind of like whoo-hoo
that's like their favorite day of the
year like six of them for 1.99
it's like nobody else wants that [ __ ]
yeah
that's how you it's just kind of well to
be honest if you like like weird ass
candy like [ __ ] candy corn or circus
peanuts or stuff that like
most people don't like like most right
thinking people like don't really like
she's a judge
we
well you're the one that went off on the
whole we went off on the whole schlitz
tangent yeah [ __ ] schlitz and then we
started talking about beer then we
started talking about candy and then we
started talking about the first that's
how it happens that's how it happened
the first [ __ ] the first [ __ ]
decent
big uh
brand beer that i had from a piss water
company
was uh it was it was one it was it was
one of them oh [ __ ] now i'm [ __ ] up i
can't remember it god that was quick
yeah i know man i had it it was on the
tip of my tongue
it was kind of killian's red that's what
it was oh that's pretty good yeah i
think it was actually miller
it might be it's miller i remember
having that sometimes it's like it's
like one notch or two notches above piss
water it's only a little bit more
expensive and they got some artificial
[ __ ] in there to make it taste pretty
good it tastes kind of like
like a red ale kinda
it isn't what it claims to be all right
that's that's like coca-cola of beers
you know i mean that [ __ ] pours out in
rivers okay i'm not sure how much brewer
brewing is actually involved in that
because that [ __ ] was mass-produced but
it did taste like a beer
it kind of had a little bit of thickness
to it
it was called killian's red and you
could get it at any honky tonk any
[ __ ]
[ __ ] bar
you can get that and you can drink it
it's good uh it's not piss water it
doesn't have that yellow [ __ ] piss
watery
light flavor it's it is red
it's nowhere near as good as a sam adams
or something but you know
passable passable you can drink it
but i think that might be malt liquor i
don't know it's hard to say that's hard
to say xanada said candy corn sucks no
one likes that [ __ ]
candy corn is good if you haven't slept
in a long time what does that have to do
with it because you need fun it's all
sugar yeah i guess if you haven't slept
a long time trying to stay awake you eat
kitty court and danny rowling said candy
corn pumpkins are better than the corn
yeah the little the little halloween
pumpkins are better just because it's
more like i mean
i don't know i'll eat them like i said
if i had to if i was like starving to
death and that's all i had like i found
a candy corn in my pocket but
i mean if if there's literally any other
candy available yeah no i'm not i used
to when i was a kid but somebody's
eating the [ __ ] because they keep making
it i'd eat them they keep making it they
were they're damn near free
they'll reach in there and grab a whole
handful of them [ __ ] after about
three hands yeah they're free because
nobody's [ __ ] sh you're just like oh
it's just so sweet so rich i can't eat
it anymore yeah well it's basically just
like solidified sugar sugar like sugar
fat sugar and corn syrup
oh my god can die
yeah i mean i don't even think there's
any flavoring in it sorry this was a
funny story camp guy said another ant
would send us a cannonball round cheese
about two and a half pound wax coated
ball one year the box opened in the yeah
we used to get those yeah one year the
box opened in the ups truck and i guess
that cheese rolled around inside the
delivery truck i just imagine the little
cheese like
that
i remember those [ __ ] cheeses they
would always sell those in those in
those catalogs you'd get around
christmas time the cheese was red wasn't
it
well that's wax it was real so it was
red
super sharp cheddar yeah it was almost
flaky yeah i remember yeah i liked it
though i liked it i mean hard to mess up
cheese that [ __ ] you give away for a
gift that's what i mean that's what you
give that with the sausage platters and
all this yeah yeah yeah yeah well it's
like we kind of wouldn't get that
sometimes because my dad always really
liked that stuff so we'd always go to
like hickory farms in the mall and like
get him a big old like
sausage and cheese around anymore
yeah i don't know if they are or not now
i will i go to bat for hickory farms
because every christmas my grandmother
used to buy me like a big box of petty
fours from hickory farms because man i
love petty force i remember you used to
get that kind of [ __ ] at the gift shop
at the [ __ ] cracker bar yeah stuff i
think you still can price okay i think
you still can probably a good place to
get it
yeah they have it on sale
they're talking about summer sausage
yeah big old summer sausages yeah [ __ ]
i mean i'm not [ __ ] your pants go to
the club
well no one's gonna want to eat it then
but well i guess for you it's win-win
because then he's like well i can have
the sausage all to myself and everyone
thinks i have a massive dick so you know
yeah like i said win win remember so
toby was packing
he's got a summer sausage
say toby have you been to hickory farms
before you can go to hickory farms daddy
got all kinds of tricks up his [ __ ]
sleeves
such as packing [ __ ]
about it zach in there zachary i don't
think yeah i haven't seen zachary i saw
him earlier today
i know that but it's like maybe he had
something else he didn't get gay with me
really didn't even get gay with him he
didn't do it
are you just didn't have a camera are
you disappointed yeah i didn't have a
camera on me i don't have a camera just
my voice you're talking dude we're
talking about the amc theater your voice
isn't sexy enough to like uh
to get people to to go gay on you i was
expecting him to [ __ ] you have to be
on the camera and he's gonna say he's
gonna say tom you're not my type i said
all right go ahead
[Laughter]
all right all right now we gotta get
back to show you hurt tom's feelings we
gotta get back to the show hurting tom's
feelings yeah we gotta destroy fun and
games we got distracted by the beer
sausage okay
sausage
[Laughter]
can that become a thing now that like
there'd just be like a few seconds of
silence and somebody will just go
sausage [ __ ] you [ __ ]
oh my god
yeah so i don't even know if i
got him before like i said we we got as
far as schlitz brewery and then ever and
then everybody like
[ __ ] went to heaven
everything went to hell i was still like
at the first paragraph for the first
thing it's what it's [ __ ] wednesday
it is um for a second i was like wait is
it and i was like oh yeah it is i forgot
what it is i have no idea what day it is
i don't sleep right anymore i don't know
what day it is
uh but yeah so uh so they're making um
does anybody remember what we were even
talking about it's this place in
milwaukee we're talking about summer
sausages and [ __ ] red wax and cheese
yeah i know it's all good and burnt horn
is talking about chorizo and eggs
yesterday they said we went from beer
from cherry beer to chocolate chips
our regulars understand they understand
it's only it's it's only like random
[ __ ] that come across and stuff
it's like
why aren't they staying on subject
matter [ __ ] off the channel
okay this is not
we're not we we are like incapable
i mean i i mean i can stay on topic but
yeah
and and some days are worse than others
okay we got to get to this we got to get
to the show all right so what i was
gonna say so schlitz brewery they had
the barrel making deal there yeah
now so it goes from owner to owner right
but then in 1922 i don't even think i
got to this part
in 1922 the building gets bought by
guess who allen frank capone okay so
they used this building as a speakeasy
during prohibition uh during the early
to mid 1920s so they had well they put
up like a business front it was supposed
to be like oh we do soda bottling in
here wink wink uh but it's actually a
speakeasy so um
so basically they there's okay so this
place has turned up on a whole bunch of
different uh lists of like most haunted
bars in america i think it was even on
that netflix show like dark tourist
which i keep meaning to watch but i just
haven't got around to it yet because it
looks kind of interesting um so they
have actually like tours
you know and uh you can do that they one
of the tours they do they do a ghost
tour and they also do a tour that's
called the cream city cannibal tour
because guess who used to hang out at
this bar good old jeffrey dahmer because
it's milwaukee so he used to hang out
this bar apparently or that's what they
say anyway so they have like a jeffrey
dahmer tour and they have a ghost tour
so one of the most famous ghosts in the
bar that a lot of people have said that
they've seen is a little girl who i
don't know if they know that her real
name is elizabeth or they just call her
elizabeth
now this poor little ghost
haunts the first floor women's bathroom
i'm always just kind of like surprised
she's like the moaning myrtle of this
guy
why when you're a ghost i don't know why
you'd want to like haunt a bathroom
forever like if you could go elsewhere
but i don't know maybe she was in the
bathrooms so she haunts the first four
bathrooms
so apparently a bunch of people that
have uh you know used the bathroom in
this establishment have heard a little
girl laughing outside the stall which
you know i guess she's peeking in at you
like laughing at your [ __ ]
you know what i mean um or sometimes
like from just outside the bathroom door
and uh also they kind of hear like
little kids footsteps like running
around like outside the bathroom like
while they're in there and then they
look and there's nobody there
and she usually like moves stuff around
in the bathroom too like moves stuff on
the counter around so i guess she just
like hangs out in the bathroom like this
little ghost i don't i don't know why
but she's weird like that she's a freaky
ghost she's into like hanging out in the
bathroom
now apparently um and like i said i'm
not really sure how they know this
information
but they think that this elizabeth ghost
is
the spirit of a little girl who before
the building was built like when this
place was still like a cemetery or like
you know just waste ground or whatever
that this little girl was like climbing
a tree in that area and she fell and
broke her neck and like died there and
now she just like hangs out in the
bathroom so there's that
another ghost that is at this place
is one named molly brennan now this girl
was
an irish girl she was 16 and she was
working as a prostitute back in the
1920s
when
the capone's owned the police
now apparently this bar underwent some
renovations in 2001 and they found like
a bunch of bones
underneath some floorboards
now some of them were animal bones but
some of them were human
so the bones uh they thought were about
70 years old which would have fit right
about in line with like the 1920s when
they thought that this uh witness girl
had died there
so what ended up happening with this was
that when it was during prohibition and
when the capone's owned the place
the main floor was you know the business
front it's like yeah we bottle sodas in
here and then and also the speakeasy
like in the back
but the top two floors were a brothel
okay
so there was like a staircase but there
was kind of like a gate there and there
was like a you know there'd be like a
bouncer or like a guard standing there
so you couldn't just like wander up the
stairs so you know so so they kind of
had that now this is very funny and i
don't know if this is true or not but i
love the the thought that was put into
this business
so remember how i said that uh you know
the the top two floors are a brothel
okay well the second floor
is like the fluffer floor
so these were like the the b squad yeah
prostitutes and they would just like you
know prepare the clientele let's call it
that yeah for the a squad prostitutes
that were on the third floor i don't
know if that's true or not but i'm just
saying that's that's what i heard no
that didn't sound right to me
that's what i said i was like i was like
that sounds like an
amazing amount of thought put into like
the system doesn't sound right to me
here i've been to brothels of course
told the story
no because everybody wants their cut
probably what they're talking about is
that you had
a tier
prostitutes on the floor
b and c tier prostitutes on other floors
that's probably what they're talking
about
yeah it's probably kind of like a
oh yeah no an eight-year girl is gonna
be in a better room
because she'll be yeah more expensive
sure because she makes more money she
can ask for more money all right and she
makes more money so she's gonna be in a
better room better facilities and she's
gonna be better the b and c ones are
they're lucky to be in there working
this
c level prostitute she's lucky to be in
there working
basically probably shouldn't be in there
working
but
she's not asking much money you know
so that's like the 80 year old woman
with no teeth no
no they're just they're usually not dead
they're usually
just
girls that guys aren't really that
interested in because it's just
something about them they're the way
they look you know
but there's somebody for everybody
you got
b and c tier guys you know what i mean
sometimes they're more comfortable with
a woman that looks like that looks like
that although i think a lot of the
problem with a lot of b and c tier guys
as we've seen and we talked about when
we did the show on in cells yeah
is that they all want like the hottest
chicks even though they are kind of like
that's not i think that's a newer
phenomenon and i've seen it myself i've
seen it myself
in korea i have often
seen i've seen it myself up in korea
where you got a guy who's you know
they're all us army guys and we were
there was a whole army of korean
good time girls they're trained by their
governments and
it is part of a [ __ ] national effort
to get every bit of [ __ ] money out of
the gi's pocket so it can go into the
korean
economy and there are some guys that are
sea tear guys they're very uncomfortable
around a tier women they know that they
can't get that normally you know what i
mean so they just they feel ugly next to
them they want to be with a woman who's
like them they're totally understandable
which to me seems a little bit more
normal it's like it seems like you would
i to me it seems like less normal that
you're like you know just like an
average looking person it's like oh i i
deserve like the hottest looking people
ever i'm just like yeah military
processes nobody deserves anybody that's
kind of like get rid of that mindset but
it's just kind of like
i don't know military prostitution in
eastern culture it's long tradition i
mean it goes back [ __ ] thousands of
years
um is it it's it's really just the
eastern version of dating they don't
have dating
you're paying for the date
they understand that
a lot of
traditional eastern women would never
date if money wasn't involved
that's being a [ __ ] giving it away like
it's not like it's not worth anything
it's a very different way of looking at
it very different but i get it though i
kind of get that so i mean i can get how
they got right and gi's are not
bad guys they're not cheating on their
wives or anything for the most part
they're young guys they're in good shape
they've been working hard in that
country helping that country's military
secure it in the case of what we were in
um
they're just trying to get entertainment
and female company and attention they're
far away from homes and that's what she
is like a geisha an entertainer then
there there is entertainment in it
it's happening in a nightclub
environment and there's apartments
behind it they take you to those
apartments
that's what it is
and uh
so there it's normal
it's not
it's not emotional in the way you know
people would think you know it's kind of
like banging the waitress this business
really
how many what you bang waitresses at
waffle house to get some to get some
free pancakes no i'm talking about it
the way you said it about about like
it's just business i was like well look
hey i can't pay for this eggs benedict
so can we like sort this out some other
way
i think a lot of people would never
really understand it you know what i
mean because it's not your girlfriend
you know i mean this is not your
girlfriend this is an inter it's kind of
like an entertainer yeah and she's
working for you she's kind of like the
waitress waiting the table yeah all
right it just happens to be sex and it's
not real um
it's not real intimate
it's it's more
uh you know
business-like yeah you know what i mean
they're talking and really the
entertainment is just talking to them it
doesn't really have anything to do with
the sex
you know
that's
and then you go back to the club and
then she moves on
that
to
somebody
all that weird to me to be honest it
doesn't seem that weird it seems it's
very normal in that culture in that
situation i think just over i think in
the west or particularly in the united
states i think it's
still has like kind of a weird stigma
about it just because of like the
puritan kind of mindset which i really
wish that we could shake off yeah well
korea and japan and china they don't
have that that's what i'm saying
like to me it just seems like like i
said you know yeah yeah you don't want
like people like cheating on their
significant others or something but
that's a different issue that doesn't
have anything to do with like the
service being available right like if
you're single and you just want to go
like have a good time at the strip club
or whatever and people are not working
there against their will then i don't
really see any problems yeah and um and
those girls were not dealing with the
general public they were all military
all u.s military that was yeah so
they're all guys in good shape and
they're
you know decent looking guys i guess you
know and they tend to go with a girl
who's about what they would get
you know
naturally it's
and see here's the thing it's a tier
korean good time girl if you're ct or
guy and coming up on here can you do
she'll probably turn you down
she doesn't have to work with you
there's all kinds of other aids here
guys [ __ ] there yeah she doesn't need
to like she doesn't need your mouth
you're right she doesn't need your money
she's in demand a lot of guys kind of
know that that's the deal so they're
kind of more realistic about who it is
they're going to approach
so it's a lot more natural than you
think that's what that seems a lot kind
of like a lot healthier
i'm going to say
rather than like every guy no matter
what they look like being like
all like hovering around like the one
hot the one super hot girl no they're
pros
they're pros they got security and
you're in their house okay they work
with who they want who they want to work
with if they don't want to work with you
they don't have to they don't [ __ ]
that's what i'm saying that seems like a
much more that seems like a much better
sense there's 30 or 40 other
[ __ ] and they they look good
what are they and they got the same
amount of money
what do they need you for right you know
so some dudes were getting lucky you
know
oh she picked me you know
just like that yeah you know and and uh
the vibe is uh not street prostitute the
vibe is more like club girl you know the
[ __ ]
cool club girls that's what they're
that's what they are
that's what i'm saying that to me like
seems a lot healthier with like
approaching it i'm not gonna lie
um
xanada said they have a buffet at the
brothel is if you want to eat chicken
wings beforehand tammy said maybe
afterwards yeah some people might like
work up an appetite i always kind of
laughed that i mean we have a very very
famous uh strip club here in orlando
called rachel's yeah they got a buffet
and they have like a big like those
strippers love jenny and they're pretty
good
and they're pretty like well known for
their steak dinners which i think is
like kind of hilarious yeah rachel's
rachel's is top notch they got good it's
a nice place it's massive
you always wanted to go on a bike night
yeah but yeah there's a bike or night
but i never go
i mean it's kind of far it's full now
yeah it's over it's way around 4 36 and
that's like 30 miles or something like
that i mean it used to be a lot closer
yeah you know and the thing is is they
[ __ ] suck money out of you well yeah
if it was kind of their whole if it was
a bang if it was back in a day where we
could go in there and spend [ __ ] 300
bucks and [ __ ] because here's the thing
if you go in there with a girl or your
girlfriend you're you're immediately
[ __ ] you're immediately a [ __ ]
superstar
yeah they love that [ __ ] they [ __ ]
love it well like i said they you have
to think like 24 like however many hours
a week they work which i'm sure is a lot
you know most of the time it's just like
these creepy old middle-aged dudes like
drooling on them and [ __ ] like that so
when somebody comes in that's like cool
and like has their girlfriend and their
girlfriend is kind of into and it's like
i mean i had so many of the girls
they're [ __ ] telling me their
problems yeah yeah and
they're making out with her on one side
someone's talking about her boyfriend
yeah
well because a lot of women don't come
in there so they're just like thank god
like there's another [ __ ] woman in
here they got little kaley and kaylee
was in love with one of them that that
red stripper didn't want anything to do
with her
uh no
i'm not a lesbian that's what it was
like oh you're not gonna entertain no
remember that yeah
yeah kaylee was heartbroken
yeah
yeah that's what i mean yeah because you
don't even well you don't really see too
many like lesbians going to strip clubs
either
like a lot of times like i said straight
girls will go like
straight as a mark or or they'll go like
with their boyfriends or with it we were
actually with a group of people like
from the club yeah because one of our
battle of the bartenders yeah so one of
our favorite bartenders was there so it
was like a big night so a lot of our
friends were there and stuff like that
but yeah they they were really
into it because well we were all nice
and like respectful we weren't like
jerks and we were goth too and those
girls are goth a lot of that's yeah so i
think they were just kind of like vibing
you know what i mean yeah uh but yeah so
so we got okay so again we got to start
i'm trying to like go back to like where
we got distracted i think i think they
like our side tracks more than a quick
storm but go ahead well that's what i
mean i don't think that i haven't
thought yeah about just doing two
sidetrack shows a week instead of like
having a topic
because because sometimes
you know i'm not trying to like be a
jerk or anything but it's like sometimes
like you know we have a topic so i try
to like stay on the topic but then it
seems like
you know we go off on a bunch of
tangents and then i'm just kind of like
well are we even going to talk about the
topic or does anybody care or anything
like that so i was like maybe we
shouldn't even bother having a topic i'm
not really sure but it well i mean in
some ways it's kind of fun
to have something like to fall back on
like to talk about if we run out of [ __ ]
to talk about but i don't know it seems
like our sidetrack shows like usually
end up being four or five hours and we
seriously never run out of [ __ ] to talk
about so there's that whole thing but
hey can you um can you get me some ice
okay i don't really need any more drinks
i'm just out of it oh my ice melted it's
kind of warm in here to be honest like
which is here
it's not usually warm in here but today
it is
wrong
danny rowling said i wonder if there's
such a thing as a ghost dancehall girl
that haunts a bar yeah i think there's a
couple a lot of um it seems like a lot
of prostitutes because a lot of the bars
that are haunted at least the ones that
i was uh that i researched
a lot of them had once been brothels and
for some reason like some of the
prostitutes like hang out and are like
ghosts there and that's what happened in
this case because
uh yeah we got distracted by the whole
uh tiered brothel situation with like
the fluffers on on the second floor and
the and the top tier girls on a or
whatever
so molly brennan uh one of the girls
that supposedly haunts this place uh was
one of the top tier ones so she was like
a third floor chick
now what ended up happening she'd been
working there for the capone's for a
while now one night she gets a visit
from one of her like from an
ex-boyfriend whose name was patrick
now patrick had come there to basically
like roxanne her like to tell her you
know you don't have to turn on the red
light or whatever so that's i mean kind
of what he did yeah you know don't quit
being uh a hoe and
run off with me and marry me and
everything will be happily ever after
blah blah blah
so um
molly's like okay that sounds like a
good idea but she's like i don't think i
can leave because maybe um the capone's
will be mad at me and will like you know
have some kind of retribution
so um and she's like plus i make a lot
of money here and i'm not really sure i
want to run off with your broke ass but
she did seem like receptive to the idea
i'm not saying that
so patrick is like well he's like well
i'm still here i'll always be here for
you and he's just kind of like trying to
get her to like
abandon
the whole life you know what i mean
um now then though
one time he comes into the bar and like
i said this is all stories i don't know
if this actually happened or not but
this is this is the story behind the
haunting
so he comes in there one night again to
try to persuade her to leave her life of
horrory hoery whatever it is
[Laughter]
and uh he ended up finding her in a
bed with his own dad oh [ __ ] daddy man
snake
that was like oh man that was like that
jeremy irons movie damage
is this legend
that's i don't know i don't know if this
really happened or not
this is just what the story behind the
haunting is you know what i'm saying
right so he comes i mean it could have
happened like i said it's not it's not
crazy yeah he comes in indiana jones
last crusade
that's right it kind of did didn't it
kind of yeah and i was because i
remember just we just watched that movie
like a couple years and i was like weird
all right
but yeah can you imagine can you imagine
like hey that's sure i mean i know she's
a prostitute and that's like her job and
stuff but it's like if that's your
girlfriend and then like you're saying
like that's she's like in your bed with
your dad like obviously that'd be super
super awkward but yeah so apparently
it's like super awkward now um okay so
remember how i said before that um that
there was like a staircase obviously
like leading up to the second and third
floors and they had like a bouncer type
guy there and there's like a gate so you
couldn't just like wander up there you
had to like you know talk to the bouncer
guy and he would like go out there so on
this particular night that patrick came
there there was a bouncer there named
sam
and uh so whatever happened that night
no one's entirely sure but before the
night was over
all three molly
patrick who was her boyfriend and sam
who was the bouncer guy were all dead
now nobody's entirely sure
what happened they think that probably
patrick after finding his girlfriend in
bed with his dad like flipped out
and killed her
and then either
sam jumped in there trying to figure and
then he killed or either that or and
then patrick jumped in there and killed
sam and then he killed himself because
he's like oh god what have i done or
they ended up killing each other
or what they're not really sure but
three people ended up dead this
particular night they know pretty much
they're pretty sure that patrick killed
molly at first but they're just not
really sure how the patrick sam
situation worked out like a vis-a-vis
like who got killed and stuff like that
so um yeah so basically all three of
these people
are supposedly still haunting the place
to this day particularly molly brennan
she's like kind of the one that uh
haunts one particular area like the
third floor like up in the penthouse but
some people have said that they uh have
seen or heard like sam or patrick as
well
and mostly
now what they do like the penthouse i
guess where some of the part of the
brothel was you can actually rent that
out i don't know if this is still true
because this article maybe was a couple
years old but um at that time you could
rent it out as an airbnb
but
the owner and i don't know if this is
true or not this might just be like one
of those paranormal dares he's like oh
only about 10 of the people that rent
that like can stay all night they
usually leave and i'm just kind of like
sir i'm not entirely sure that i buy
that that's like i said that sounds like
a dare like are you brave enough to stay
here like to get people to stay there
i'd be curious to look it up on airbnb
and see like what the waiting list is
like
but um but they said that like a lot of
people that have gone to this place and
stayed in this particular airbnb they
said uh they hear like voices male
voices female voices a lot of bumping a
lot of um a lot of people have reported
hearing like a woman's high heels what
sounds like a woman's high heels walking
around in the middle of the night and
nobody's there um they said another
thing that's real common is that people
feel like they someone's sitting next to
them on the bed
and that sometimes they'll wake up and
there's like an imprint like a body like
in the bed next to them like somebody
had been laying down next to them so i'm
thinking that that mostly happens like
up in the part that they rent out
nowadays like uh as an airbnb
so that was just the first place like i
said now some of the places have like
longer histories and some of them just
have short ones so i'm just kind of like
go around but i'm going to run to the
bathroom first because
so
talk about something all right i'll talk
about something while she's talk about
something all right let's see who's in
the comment sections
all right
i don't know who cine eater is
you can he's thought about uh pink floyd
and all right
uh there's zach number two zach
anderson's in there he's a new guy
what's up zack
hugo is trying to get me to [ __ ] wear
the white wig i'm not wearing a white
wig today i might when i get if i
get if i get [ __ ] up i'll put a wig on
later okay
um
we'll see which one i put on i don't
know
um
what i was gonna say let me go ahead and
plug my other channel
uh
you can find me on twitch
tom 13 o'clock
all lower case there's no apostrophe in
it just tom 13 o'clock i'm in there i'm
playing um
a
tomb raider legend and then i'm then i'm
gonna play anniversary and i'm gonna do
underworld
and it's gonna be fun and uh you can uh
talk to me over i got my headset on you
can talk to me we can talk about
anything you want to talk about anything
not suitable for this show we can talk
about over there
so you can friend me every time i plug
it i get two or three more they only got
six over there right now
um
all right jenny's back
i'm back yeah i just gave him a
commercial
[Laughter]
my twitch channel i'm gonna plug jenny
too all right jenny
jenny her [ __ ] new diet and exercise
routine's working out crazy crazy man
her waist is [ __ ] shrinking in like
that she's getting becoming fortified
looking i'm gonna do a photo shoot and
i'm gonna share it
already got a picture of a booty on
[ __ ] on twitch that's my banner my
banner is your booty
you know you're putting on makeup where
you had you when you were at the [ __ ]
baby
yeah yeah with your booty hanging out in
the [ __ ] boots and [ __ ] it's just
booty that's your picture that's my
banner it's the banner
you didn't tell me that yeah yeah
i mean his booty's on the band i mean i
don't care but
the thing is my twitch account is a free
account came with xbox one and i don't
think i can get i don't know if what
they call them super chats i haven't
seen anything about that
and when i did that stream today when uh
when zach was on there
the the stream wasn't saved and i didn't
see any option on how to put it into my
stream yet i'm going to do more research
that you got to figure it out i may have
to pay for that or something
yeah that might be right because a lot
of times they'll give you like a lot of
[ __ ] for free but you can't you can't
get full fun yeah like limited kind of
functionality yeah i think i got limited
functionality but if i get enough if i
get enough um
uh followers over there and can get some
super chats maybe i'll uh enable full
functionality it's probably only five
bucks a month anyway
yeah it's probably like super cheap you
can probably afford it
i mean you know mm-hmm
uh guama khan said uh tom you're a fan
of gona guy right yeah yeah what's your
opinion on cutie honey
i don't know cutie honey yeah i haven't
seen that one santa said i know a lot
about twitch i can help tom oh who who
says i said that okay yeah we'll talk
about it later
yeah because i was like i don't uh i
don't use twitch but i mean i i could
probably figure it out because i figured
out like everything else that i had to
do but you know my favorite go to guy
series is one of his least favorite one
one of his least liked ones as i like to
get a robo g
a lot of people liked the first get a
robot but i like g
i like that and i was [ __ ] big fan i
got that on on dvd and i also got the
original the old ghetto robo i have that
too
and um
got with english subs japanese with
english subs man i love the theme songs
yeah theme songs are great
uh and then uh uh i really like to ufo
grandizer
i gotta and i have a lot of the figures
frank my friend owns a company called hl
pro
who made a lot of [ __ ] grand eyes or
figures and uh
great mazinger and mazinger z and
jig and all the greats
he's a friend of mine to make some the
diecast shogokans and stuff i have whole
collections of them but they're all in
boxes but i must have [ __ ]
six thousand six thousand dollars worth
of [ __ ] it
japanese figures
it's ridiculous i got addicted i mean
yeah i remember like addicted for a
while i could and i keep forgetting
because you didn't get them all at once
like you'd get one by one or two like a
month or something like that yeah like a
couple hundred dollars a piece yeah so
but now like you go in the man cave and
i'm like holy [ __ ] i didn't realize
thousands of dollars i didn't realize
you had that many i don't even display
them really anymore but
they're all [ __ ] mint in the boxes i
even got the 12 inch action figures of
[ __ ] um
uh
uh
what do i have i got [ __ ] um
ufo granddizer and i got [ __ ] um
mazinger and great mazinger
12 inch action figures fully articulated
they're good
got a bunch of little [ __ ]
diecast
[ __ ] i got gadger with this saucer
die-cast metal
[ __ ]
duke fleas [ __ ] trike
[ __ ]
the spazer
diecast spazer [ __ ] i got three of
the [ __ ] grand eyes are figures die
cast metal
um got a bunch of bandai stuff too oh i
gotta get on the subject i'll talk about
that [ __ ] all day long my favorite one's
g get a robo g man that's a good one
fighting the pandemonium end of empire
he fights the forces of hell one of them
is the [ __ ] demonic spirit of hitler
satan and hitler
yeah
ghetto rubble's gotta fight them okay
the pandemonium empire
i wish i could have a [ __ ] outfit
called pandemonium empire yeah i bet you
like some bad ass [ __ ] man i bet you
like general bride yeah the pandemonium
empire
murder reported said jenny what's the
secret to weight loss time's in glory's
bastards got it not eating that's pretty
much it not eating and hormonal balance
and riding 20 miles a day on my on a
bicycle on my bike i'm like
[Laughter]
you got to do i mean i do eat but i just
i can't eat that much like today i've
had i have eaten one small meal
as you pass your thirties and get into
your phone or two cups of coffee your
body is resistant to change because
you're you're not producing the amount
same amount of hormones
if you want good if you want good body
change and transformation you gotta
increase the amount of hormones and then
you work out and your body will respond
i ain't natural she's not really natural
well and the thing about it is that
everybody's different everybody's
metabolism is different like i said i'm
slow my metabolism is very very slow so
if i want to lose weight i have to like
eat
very very little like some people could
probably eat a lot more than me and get
away with and still lose weight but i
can't so i generally have to keep it to
one or two
very small meals a day i do not usually
eat breakfast and it's hard for me
because my instincts are to feed a
[ __ ]
yeah i love to feed a [ __ ] let
me tell you
i'm gonna know you're gonna have i'm
like somebody's grandma that's what you
gotta eat dude that's what i'm telling
you and it's like i kept telling you i'm
like you're exactly like my grandma
that's probably like why i got fat when
i was like uh like a like a preteen yeah
because that my grandmother who was
skinny her whole entire life because she
had super super fast metabolism uh so
she could eat what she wanted and not
gain any weight yeah so she was always
kind of like and this was a lot of
southern people are like this too it's
like if you were getting too thin what's
the matter with you
yeah yeah like you know don't you want
more of that don't you want like so she
was just everything was like butter and
gravy and everything like that and like
sometimes i didn't want that but people
in the southern regions of the united
states and central america too mexicans
and central americans the same way we
all survive lots of famines famines and
wars
so the all the people that have fast
metabolisms died who was left over
people who are famine resistance they're
short people that can keep weight on
them even that's what i'm saying i could
i could not eat for probably several
months and i'd probably still be alive
yeah i can put a lot of muscle on fast i
can put a lot of [ __ ] fat on fast
and um
if and beyond the age of 45 if you're
you're going to start if you're a short
southerner or a mexican as [ __ ] as
mexicans in the in the [ __ ] comment
section like [ __ ] khan i don't know
if khan's in there kind of ocelot i
don't know if he's in there he'll tell
you
after 40 we start putting on [ __ ]
weight because yeah so for me it got
even harder right like after like it was
it was really hard for me when i was
like in my teens and 20s even but then
like after i was like you know in my 40s
then it got even more difficult so now i
just have to eat it doesn't matter how
much doesn't have our metabolisms are
real resistant to starvation real
efficient
just give a person give us a small
amount of food and we'll just keep
weight on and you can work and work and
work and work and work if that's not
going anywhere you're just fine yep your
[ __ ] your your economy mode yeah you
know [ __ ] you get a thousand miles to
a gallon
yeah yeah which like i said is good in
some situations in starvation not so
much in uh modern day america not so
much
where where food is plentiful thousand
mile a gallon [ __ ]
you know my so i keep trying to tell my
body i just you're just like look i
don't we're not starving there's food
everywhere yeah okay it's like because
no my body's like no i i need these
precious fat cells i'm just gonna like
i'm just gonna just these ones right
here like in in your big fats i'm not a
doctor
i'm gonna tell you what a doctor's gonna
tell you it's all over youtube
endocrinologists and everything
if you're a woman
approaching menopause or get you know in
your 30s
or after your menopause
about 20 milligrams a day and 20
milligrams a week of [ __ ]
testosterone and anthoid or recipient
and that'll keep your metabolism moving
forward with a man
between 175 to 200
you can bump it up a little bit more if
you want to speed certain things up then
there's some things out there you can
get through hrt clinics you always do
this [ __ ] under a doctor's supervision
but
small touches of winstrol here and there
can help and
women women require so little i mean
we're talking about drops
they don't need very much you get they
get a lot a lot of bang for their buck
on a woman this doesn't cost anything to
do things for them
all right
if you go to a hrt clinic for a woman
you're gonna spend a lot of money
but if you know your [ __ ] this and that
and sometimes somebody can loan somebody
something
because what a woman takes is nothing a
man wouldn't even miss it
you know but you're just trying to keep
the metabolism going so they can burn
fat when they work out they actually
burn fat when they diet they actually
burn fat they actually build muscle they
don't lose muscle
so you keep that shape
that's all it is
santa said stop eating them grits
we don't eat grits that much anymore i
haven't had i don't i remember the last
time i had great got a lot of grits in
storage
i mean we do but yeah we haven't i think
the last time i ate it was got to be
like months and months grits the civil
war food there man that kept the south
alive during during that [ __ ] and
reconstruction
but that's another reason why a
[ __ ] gets fat you know
yes trying to live off of corn it's very
bad that's mexicans it's very fatty
they've been living off corn for
thousands of years
grinding it and [ __ ] garage down they
can keep well like i said it's good in
famine conditions because it's it's high
caloric content which sometimes that's
what you want yeah it doesn't give you
the greatest
shape
but it'll keep you from dying yeah which
like i said sometimes that's all you can
ask for right but like i said when in
situations like in modern times when
food is plentiful
you know you don't you don't need that
exactly
so you know it's our own body's kind of
like
yeah kicking our own asses yeah uh all
right so let's talk a little bit about
uh ernestine and hazel's now this is in
memphis tennessee
and according to one website i saw it
said there was best dive bar in
tennessee i don't know if that's true
i've been at tennessee but it was a long
time ago
uh and home of america's best burger
again i don't know if that's true i'm
sure there's a lot of stiff competition
in that regard because i've had some
pretty goddamn good burgers
um so this is a two-story bar and it was
actually originally built as a pharmacy
but just like the last place we talked
about was a brothel at one time but i
feel like every kind of old building was
a brothel at one time it was a big
business that's what i'm saying there's
no internet that's what i'm saying it's
like no strip clubs right so it's like
what else are you gonna do
um and was also like a concert venue and
just like a regular cafe stuff like that
now uh we don't know if this is true or
not but the story goes that at least
13 people have died in this building
which
sounds like a lot but i guess if it's
been there a long time it's not really
that crazy
over the years there's actually a cod
oh okay
uh let's see
so one of the things that and this is
kind of like um
the lake what was that place called that
we did the lake club club horror yeah
this is this sounds like a little bit
like that where they get uh one of the
big things that they get is like phantom
piano music like coming from upstairs
and then you go up there and there's
nobody there which that was another
thing that uh happened at the lit club
place that we did the haunting show
about um and everybody like hears
footsteps when there's nobody there this
is my favorite thing
they said the jukebox comes on by itself
sometimes
and sometimes i guess it's like an old
style jukebox like with the records and
they said sometimes like the needle will
drop on a record that is absolutely like
specific to whatever is going on in the
place at the time or like whatever the
conversation is
and uh this one thing i said said uh
that i read said that there were people
and then they were talking about james
brown and then they said all of a sudden
the jukebox like came on like right on i
feel good like all of a sudden and like
i don't even know like the jukebox
wasn't even on it was unplugged or
something like that yeah so it's that
kind of [ __ ] it seems like it was all
musical stuff um but i think some people
have like reported some apparitions
there as well but it seems like mostly
like sounds like footsteps and music and
stuff like that and some people uh have
also said that
they feel like hands touching them like
when they're walking like
ghosts are like [ __ ] molesting them
and whatnot
then we got uh old town pizza which is a
restaurant ambar and that's in portland
oregon
and their most famous ghost is a woman
named
nina now she's been around uh for about
a century that they know of
she was actually again there's there's
some more brothel [ __ ] she was a sex
slave
now um where the where old town pizza is
used to be a place called the merchant
hotel and again there was kind of like a
brothel in there and i guess she was
kind of like forced into prostitution
there
um and this place is over
portland oregon has like a bunch of
those shanghai tunnels like underneath
yeah
so um
[Music]
so she's like working in there and
apparently these missionaries came to
town
and said hey um if you give up
prostitution we'll like take you away
will rescue you
and she's like okay get me the [ __ ] out
of here
um but the pimps and stuff that she was
working for
decided you're not going anywhere and
they threw her down the elevator shaft
so you know that's nice
um a lot of times what happens is they
were kind of in an indentured servitude
they put them up room and board and then
they said yeah they would owe money that
they had to work off for the room and
the board yeah that happened a lot
that's usually how it was
it was kind of like uh
they overcharged them for a lot of stuff
they were never really able to work off
that debt they were there yeah that's
how they until they really weren't worth
anything they just kind of kick them out
yeah and then they like end up [ __ ]
homeless probably yeah yeah that's
usually what happened because you
couldn't like or the problems closed
down get people to go to jail and it
would be dissolved yeah and then she's
just on the street again yeah i mean
it's shitty i've read um i read a book a
long time ago about um some people that
have been brought over like from ireland
and stuff like that under that situation
where they were indentured servants they
were like hey um we'll pay for your
passage over to the to the u.s yeah if
you work for us for seven years or
whatever the [ __ ] it was but yeah there
was always some kind of thing where
yeah they wouldn't ever there was more
to it than that yeah um the the irish
indentured servitude was kind of a cover
story because some of them were
straight-up slaves
yeah some of them were straight up
slaves well that's what they were kind
of talking about in this book um
a lot of mysterious [ __ ] things
happened in the united states uh
especially centered around the railroad
and the irish and the chinese
there are railroad lines where in
explicit inexplicably there are mass
graves of chinese and irish on the side
of the damn railroad tracks not a word
nobody knows what happened
i think labor revolts
and the railroad had their own courts
they could pass death sentences on
[ __ ] their employees
people don't realize how powerful
corporations used to be
and uh there must have been some kind of
revolt in one place and they had
pinkertons and [ __ ] and this is in the
area where they had gatlin guns and i
think they just machine gunned a bunch
of them well i'm sure that happened on
the railroad tracks
and they'd bury them like nothing ever
happened and they just ordered more more
of these irish and chinese slaves really
is what they were
no no regard
for anything and some people go well the
united states has [ __ ] up campus it
wasn't even the united states it was
[ __ ] it was the railroad corporation
doing it
it mind-boggling don't trust anybody all
right i'm tom i'm thomas [ __ ]
ross i'm paying attention they haven't
changed the game the game is the same
it's the same ruling class
they're just hiding it better
don't trust any people
good
they don't like you they're just trying
to make money
money and power [ __ ] them
santa said i was telling tom about a
child's grave near me from when the gold
mines had eight-year-olds working for
him yeah it's a creepy spot send those
kids into the mines they're small yeah
that's pretty much why they sent them
down there because they were a little
yeah well that was standard operating
procedures it was it was all throughout
england yeah they did that there was
little english children and irish
children and everything they did that
here too it was uncomfortably recent
that they actually were like yeah maybe
we shouldn't do that we shouldn't be
sending little kids well there was no
such thing as childhood up until
recently yeah not really like i said
that was a very soon you could walk and
talk you were working yeah get to work
rat yeah
and who know and they would who knows
what the sex thing was all about for all
we know the bosses were
for were [ __ ] cracking them little
girls and [ __ ] you know probably were oh
i'm sure because
if they could i'm sure they were yeah
because they were
doing bad sexual [ __ ] to him in
orphanages at that same time
it was probably widespread
probably
they were [ __ ] savages i mean well
yeah and like i said people [ __ ] about
nowadays and there's a lot of bad [ __ ]
happening nowadays too but it's like i
would not want to go back then because i
think it was worse that's what i mean i
think it was way worse because there was
really no
expectation that you would be treated
like a human being it's like especially
if you were poor or you for an immigrant
or something like that or a child um you
were basically just expendable nobody
thought if you was like a person you
were just kind of like i think that's a
fairly recent phenomenon that that
people actually
feel like other people are people even
if they're the whole american
constitution you know what i mean about
[ __ ] having human rights and the
rights to do this and that that was all
theoretical
that was not a reality when that was
written it was something they were
striving for yeah and it did kind of
come about
you have to fight hard to keep that
because corporations that own the
government want nothing to do with that
they want to go back to damn monarchy
that's what they want
because that way is the rich people rule
and it makes a lot easier for them
you gotta fight for your freedoms as
that's you and for your rights of party
and you must fight for your rights apart
you know what i said you know
you know i had to put that beastie boys
do all of that
i don't know why i just thought of this
but at my
senior prom
they legit played that beastie boys song
three times yeah over they can i wasn't
even i was only there for like an hour
and then i [ __ ] it and then i pissed
off and went to rocky horror because the
problem was boring so you know there you
go yeah but just remember the
constitution in the american values were
only [ __ ] theoretical they were the
theoretical goals of the revolution and
they said in there that the revolution
had to be constant because they'll
[ __ ] creep up on you they'll take
away anything you get
if you give them if you if you relax
they'll just creep up on you
and take everything from you
and history shows this not in the united
states
world history shows that humans are bad
humans are talking monkeys they have to
be kept in check
rich people
are dangerous
you got to keep them in check poor
people are dangerous too just look at
look at television you know people are
dangerous
but we all got to learn how to live
together how to [ __ ]
you want to have a cool place to live
and be able to do what you want without
[ __ ] other other people over and you
definitely want these corporations to
tell you how to live
the railroads were the worst really in
history well like i said they they
straight up murdered people they would
say that blew up [ __ ] cities that too
if a city gave them any problem they
just [ __ ] routed they routed the
railroads around the city and starved
that city out it was just advantage
should be gone two years later because
they knew that they it's like well you
know they had all the power like you
couldn't really do anything about that
they laid the railroads laid siege to
new york city and made your new york's
new york city bend to the will of the
railroad that took about three days
it just stopped delivering
and new york was like yeah okay okay i
think there was like yeah it's like what
the [ __ ] else can you do that was like
the only game in town and they knew it
they did so they took advantage
you know yeah all right so where was i
okay so uh yeah the pimps throw nina the
prostitute she's trying to escape
uh because she was an indentured
servitude and they throw her down an
elevator shaft which seems kind of weird
because it's just kind of like well
if you didn't want her to leave
then
is it better that you just like threw
her down an elevator shaft because now
she's also useless to you why didn't you
just let her leave now you've got like a
murder rap maybe they didn't really care
i don't know maybe they're just mad so
they threw her down an elevator shaft
now the story goes that she kind of like
scratched her name into a brick
at the bottom of the elevator shaft
because i guess maybe she didn't die
right away
and that brick is now like they have it
like part of one booth
and apparently nina's ghost
sometimes will appear in this booth and
like watch you eat
which seems a little weird it's like
you're just sitting there eating your
chicken and waffles or whatever
or your avocado toast and all of a
sudden
this ghost like pops and just like hey
what you got there can i have a bite
yeah so they said that um sometimes when
you're eating in there like you smell
like a perfume kind of smell like uh
kind of faint or
some people have seen her said it looks
she looks very ghostly and she's like in
a black dress and she's just kind of
sitting there like checking out people
eating uh and that's nina so like i said
we talked about the shanghai tunnels
like how this is above the shanghai
tunnels if you don't know what those are
those are kind of like the
all of these like networks underneath
the city all these little passageways
and stuff there's opium dens down there
and they basically would kidnap people
and send them out to sea like i said you
get shanghaied yeah then they put you on
a ship
they drug you and put you on a ship and
then you'd wake up and you'd be out in
the middle of the pacific ocean and be
like well [ __ ] me
uh what no no oh i thought you were
going to show me some people next thing
you know you were in [ __ ] shanghai
china they're forcing you to work yeah
and you got back home but it might take
five years
that's what i'm saying it's like can you
imagine just you're just like yeah you
know happily like out of the bar one
night getting drunk and all of a sudden
next day you wake up and you're yeah and
they got a free five years labor out of
you you're working on ships and [ __ ]
[ __ ] loading and unloading cargo
i mean you know
and that's the thing you don't have i
didn't want to go to sea back then you
had to [ __ ] force them
well and the thing too is that if you
didn't have money or resources or
anything like that you were kind of
hosed i mean like you didn't really have
any options well it made sense though
think about it think about it from the
from the from the crew's point of view
you got guys on the ship and they're
going man we're short-handed and
[ __ ] aren't joining
and you're you're drinking at the bar
and you say look at that worthless
[ __ ] he's just a bum listen take
him with us
yeah we're going to kidnap him kidnap
that [ __ ] make him work with us
like he's not doing anything just
drinking
maybe we might be able to make him a
semen and that's that day that dude
could be like a heart surgeon or
something like you don't know that guy
they picked dudes that they'd see
[ __ ] you know in the bar
we're gonna take that dude with us he'd
be drunk in the corner they'd [ __ ]
pull his ass out of there
he'd wake up he'd be on a ship
no i don't want to be here no you're
working we're going to throw you over
[ __ ] board
you know
we're not going to feed you unless you
start [ __ ] helping too rough to feed
you yeah we'll be back in this area in
about about a year and we'll let you off
but i think a lot of guys ended up being
[ __ ] merchant marines and semen just
by being shanghaied
but being drafted
it's a bar room draft
pretty much that's what it is yeah yeah
yeah they just like snatch it right off
the street yeah and then next thing you
know it's a pirate's life for me
they don't want to go back you know so
maybe like they do from jaws it like a
doll's eye
oh quinn
[Laughter]
they were [ __ ] hardcore back then
xander said there's a ghost of a
prostitute in the mizbot hotel in
southern nevada they call her the lady
in red she was killed by her boyfriend
in the early 1900s her room is still
preserved the way it was when she was
killed you can find pictures on google
i mean so many
poor prostitutes they just get killed
all the time
and then they have to like hang it's bad
enough they get murdered and then they
like have to hang around like in
bathrooms and like in bars and stuff
like that it's probably a tourist in the
place
tails well i think a lot of it is but
there's still like fun stories anyway
yeah so apparently okay so there's a
place in new york new york which is
called one if by land two if by sea
and this place supposedly is haunted by
aaron burr
no
aaron burr
this is a now the restaurant uh
where it sits actually used to be aaron
burr's carriage house back in the old
days
and so a lot of people think that him
and his daughter theodosia
like kind of hung around just because
they want to [ __ ] with people so you
know what i mean so they're always kind
of like creeping around the stairs
knocking [ __ ] over
you know poking at the people at the bar
[ __ ] like that just being dicks
essentially
um
so they said they had like some
paranormal team in there and they said
there are actually 20 ghosts there from
all different time periods i don't know
if that's true or not how do they know
how that sounds like they're trying to
get people to go to the hotel that's
what i'm saying that's well see that's
why you can't really
trust any of this stuff like i said
there's still fun stories i don't really
necessarily believe any of them are true
because i've never i've never actually
been anywhere like i said that where's
the reports of the phenomenon that's
what i'm saying okay that's what i'm
saying but like i said well this is just
like a fun show we're not going we're
not going like [ __ ] that way we're
not scientific
right yeah i mean we do kind of
i don't know i just like these kind of
be fun but i do kind of like
i get what you're saying i don't really
believe any of these stories at face
value i'm just going by like with the
legends i'm just saying like this is
what the legend says that's what he goes
i don't necessarily believe the [ __ ] i
don't even believe that some of the
stuff that they say happened back then
happened i don't think some of that
stuff happened i'm not saying that
people didn't get murdered in places
because they did obviously people get
murdered all the time but it's really
easy to make up stories about vague
people that don't have are not well
documented
prostitutes weren't well-read that's
what i'm saying so maybe that's why so
many of the ghosts are
you know sailors and pirates yeah
because it's like they wouldn't really
be any records of that person
necessarily yeah so it's just kind of
like yeah oh yeah there was this chick
here and that wasn't her real name she
was just like she was a hooker or
whatever and she got murdered and like i
said i'm not saying somebody didn't get
murdered there i'm just saying
you know we don't we don't know once
it was a long time ago a lot of
prostitutes didn't work under their own
real names anymore that's what i was
just saying it's like so that's why
maybe that's why a lot of the ghosts are
prostitutes you know can't check
anything
all right so here now here's a place in
your old stomping grounds new orleans
okay
lafitte's blacksmith shop okay have you
ever been there nope
murder hornet said my crotch is haunted
from girlfriend's past oh yeah it's
called crabs
ghost crabs
but wait that's a real thing isn't it a
ghost crab i don't know it's a little
crab that's like white yeah yeah i don't
like any crabs crabs suck why they're
ugly no they're not they're cute
whatever they're cute and they're
delicious
[Laughter]
which is that's it's a really more it's
a moral quantum quandary for me
um so yeah
so lafitte's blacksmith shop
is in one of the oldest buildings in the
french quarter so the blacksmith shop
bar is actually uh obviously named after
jean and pierre lafitte who were you
know pirates kind of smugglers pirates i
don't remember this place in the early
19th century it's what's what street is
it on uh i don't know it's not on
bourbon
i don't know it just says it says it's
in the french quarter okay and it's
apparently like pretty famous because it
turned up on like a whole bunch of lists
i never used to go to the [ __ ]
bourbon street that's all tourists there
zack said wait tom you lived in new
orleans yeah he did no i mean well he
didn't live in new orleans he lived
there he used to go there on the
weekends yeah he lived in uh it was past
christian mississippi in mississippi
yeah and it was just like a short drive
yeah like 35 minutes 40 minutes yeah so
used together like on weekends yeah that
was where the golf clubs were yeah
i love that area that was before katrina
uh it's not good anymore because it's
built up
it's there's too many people there now
but back in those days it was like the
right level like there was goth
girls there and [ __ ] they were friends
of mine and there was a
not a bunch of them it'd be like 10 of
them and you knew them all and you'd all
hang out it was a good time good time
memories yeah i married one of them my
first wife was one of them
but she was the cutest one
she said well of course she had of
course she was accused when i got
pictures to prove
[Laughter]
she was cute you're only gonna pick the
cutest one what's that you're only gonna
pick the cutest yeah of course it was
kiss watch
there named tiffany
he's called me tiffany a couple of yeah
by accident
[Laughter]
i want me to shop for a long time let me
show you pictures of tiffany i got
pictures of tiffany on the phone no i
don't have it on this one no it's on the
other one yeah that's your new one
that's my new one that's my old one yeah
all the all the stuff's on oh is it oh
okay
and pictures there
yeah because i uh they when i switched
over they took my sd card
oh and they put it in the other one and
they all went they're all over there oh
okay i got you sorry honey pictures over
so yeah so this place blacksmith shop
bar
was uh apparently like the p john and
pierre lafitte like used this as kind of
a base of operations uh during the 19th
century early 19th century
now
although uh this bar will say that it's
the oldest bar in the united states
because it claims that it was founded in
1775
no one's entirely sure i mean i think i
don't know if like i think the building
was there but i don't know if it was a
bar all that time um they said that
actually they got their first official
liquor license in 1933 right after
prohibition was appealed so no one's
entirely sure if it's really the oldest
bar they do kind of like tell everybody
that
so uh it will surprise no one to know
that john lafitte is the
ghost that's seen here most often and a
bunch of people have said that they've
seen his like a full-body apparition of
him like walking along like back and
forth along the floor you know
um
and he just kind of like skulks around
around by the fireplace so like uh
numerous people have said they've seen
him
and uh apparently too
there was another story about uh the
upstairs that there was a woman that
rented the upstairs area and she ended
up committing suicide up there
and a lot of people that have gone up
there uh i guess there's like places to
stay up there like maybe it's kind of
like an in sort of situation
so they said i don't know if anyone's
seen her but they said they actually
hear her like whispering in your ear at
night like sometimes she'll come in your
room and like talk to you
so there's that and people like felt
presences and that kind of stuff
and uh apparently too
there's another thing that happens there
that some people have said that they
just see not so much an apparition but
it's just kind of like red eyes
that
kind of look out from the corners of the
first floor like you know the room of
the first floor like they just see these
like disembodied eyes looking out that
are like red
and um you know so some people are like
ooh demons but
that's kind of like
like you turn like that you kind of see
him out of the corner of your eye and
then you turn and look
and then they just kind of like fade you
know what i mean so some people have
like reported seeing that too so that's
like that place in uh new orleans
now another place in this place is in
chicago and it's called the tonic room
and uh
so what happened at this place
this place had kind of a pretty colorful
history i guess like a lot of these
places have
so in the 1920s this was the hangout of
the irish north side gang
and then uh the american chapter of the
golden dawn used to hang out in there
so you know golden dawn that's kind of
like an occult
type of [ __ ]
and uh somebody i don't know if this is
true or not i kind of doubt it but one
girl in the 1930s said that she went
with her dad to one of these golden dawn
meetings
and there was a good old ritual killing
there's some like old satanic panic [ __ ]
come back again in the basement
so uh so a lot of people have mostly i
think what people see in here is just
kind of like um
like mists like they take like they
don't see anything and they take a
picture and then there's like weird
misty looking like figures in it um but
some people have said that they've seen
like an apparition that looks kind of
like a gangster so some people have seen
that as well uh this place was actually
taken over
uh and was in a cult store for a while
in the 1960s like that was run by like a
male witch type dude but yeah so i think
the kind of the main claim to fame of
this place other than the gangster ghost
is that it was
the golden dawn used to hang out there
so people are like ooh satanism that
kind of stuff
so here's a place called the pioneer
saloon this is in good springs nevada
now this place i saw i was looking at
pictures this place this i'm not real
into like you know western kind of stuff
but
this place looks pretty cool it just
looks like an old
saloon like back from that time period
they said so much so that they've used
it like in tv shows and movies and stuff
like that that were you know period
accurate
you know where they had to like shoot in
a saloon or something they shoot in
there because it looks exactly like that
so this place was actually built in 1913
uh it's about a half hour from las vegas
and
possibly maybe the oldest
active
manufactured stamped tin structure
in the state possibly the country so
it's really cool looking i think it's
like a really cool looking place and
like i said i'm not into that whole like
western aesthetic but it is like really
really cool looking
so the best known story about this place
is about famous people the story goes
that clark gable who back in the day was
married to carol lombard
and what happened there was that clark
gable uh was reportedly sitting in this
bar
for three days when his wife carol
lombard she was on a plane that went
missing
and so he was sitting there while he was
waiting to hear
news of what had happened to her
so he basically was sitting in this bar
for like three straight days
and then they found out that you know
the plane had crashed
uh and you know so there was so he was
in there so we found out so
to this day they say that uh carol
lombard's ghost haunts the ladies room
again another ghost like haunting the
bathroom why would you want to hunt the
bathroom
why would you want to hunt the bathroom
it was it was a place of
socialization i guess
i guess i never really got that though
because i do kind of feel like there's
whole okay i know how guys have this
perception that it's like oh the ladies
and they all go in the bathroom together
and stuff like that like they talk which
you do sometimes like if you gotta like
say some [ __ ] to your girlfriends that
you don't want
the men hearing yeah you go in the
bathroom but to be honest in my
experience like a lot of women go to the
bathroom like in clubs and stuff by
themselves so they don't like get
because they don't want like weirdos
like creeping up on them and [ __ ] you
got to go like in pairs and stuff me and
vadim kanyev he was a [ __ ] ex-russian
soldier i used to hang out in [ __ ]
boston up at [ __ ] man race it was the
goth club it was
it was the [ __ ] weirdest [ __ ] it was
after the [ __ ] cold war i got out of
the army and moved to boston and started
hanging out in [ __ ] goth clubs
soviet union collapsed i meet a [ __ ]
ex-russian soldier in there who's gothic
he was infantry too his name was vadim
kanyev we became real good friends
he owned a computer [ __ ] shop he had
a long black straight hair i showed her
to jenny because boy he's cute he looked
like an antonio the russian antonio
banderas
he lived in a whole [ __ ] house like a
haunted house full of [ __ ] strippers
that were also hit like his sales agents
also at his [ __ ] computer shop
we were allowed in the girls bathroom at
man right
we were going to the girls bathroom with
girls to make out with them and [ __ ]
[ __ ] hanging out there [ __ ] 20 30
40 minutes and [ __ ] and the girls would
be coming and going inside the stalls
and they didn't even notice that really
that we were in there the castle was
kind of like that yeah it was fun i mean
there were two bathrooms but nobody
really cared yeah yeah yeah we were
[ __ ] sitting up
we'd be up there just like whatever the
counter where the sinks were in the
[ __ ] and the [ __ ] glass and [ __ ]
me and kanye would be up there [ __ ]
and and the girls would [ __ ] light up
a joint be smoking smoking weed inside
the bathroom the [ __ ] girls bathroom
was [ __ ] awesome
at uh and and only me and vadim were
allowed in there
because we were so [ __ ] sorry i was
just thinking like pretty pig it's like
what is this what is this you got a
candy machine in here yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah i'm not wearing a girl
like the tampons
and they're in the [ __ ] stalls and
[ __ ] taking the leak [ __ ] yelling out
and talking to us [ __ ] why we were up
on it yeah that's fine
girl's bathroom girl the bathroom's a
magical place the girl's bathroom
maybe that's why so many ghosts haunted
girls yeah
it was a magical place back in the
[ __ ] man raised at the goth club
[Laughter]
honestly like i said that was one of the
things that i always kind of liked about
the castle was i don't know if it's
still like this because i've been there
in a while but i think it probably still
is but yeah like they had one bathroom
was here which was ostensibly the ladies
room and then there was one bathroom
here which was ostensibly the men's room
but
nobody like the doors were just open and
like nobody really cared which one i
mean you could go in there and buy
clothes cigarettes it was like a chick
sitting there that would like sell you
them for a quarter or whatever and uh
you know and nobody really cared like
people are just in there yeah putting
makeup on at the bathroom and at the
sink and
at the mirror and people are just in
there it was fine like everything nobody
cared nobody cared but uh yeah people
make it out in there all kind of stuff i
hate public bathrooms i don't get it
yeah i mean it depends on where it is no
that was it mad race man but that's not
public that's like
that was like the vault from new york
but it was
boston's version of the vault
that was a cool club it's gone now that
was back in the 90s
that's gone
[ __ ] i was hanging out with [ __ ]
with [ __ ] uh switchblade symphony
tina root and everything i'd even know
who they were
i don't even know who [ __ ] switch
place tiffany was
i heard them live and i was like yeah
it's a pretty good band but i never i
didn't really put two and two together i
really hadn't heard them yet yeah yeah
so poor carol lombard she apparently
like dies in a plane crash
and because she wasn't even in this bar
clark gable was in the bar like waiting
and then he found out that she had died
and then she gets stuck here hot in the
ladies bathroom evidently
um also there are in the side of the
building there's a bunch of bullet holes
where there was like a gunfight that
took place there so obviously like a lot
of the ghosts that were participated in
the gunfight uh also haunt the place
and there are also two other ghosts that
people have seen one of them is an old
guy who's like a miner
and the other one is another prostitute
a lady named ruby which i kind of feel
like yeah ruby that's that's a
prostitute name uh yeah so she actually
didn't even i don't even think she
she might have hung out in the bar but i
think her thing was mostly like a hotel
that was like next door that burned down
so maybe it burned down and she was like
well i don't just want to like ghost
around in this [ __ ]
ashes i'm just gonna go over here to
this bar and like haunt this place not
the bathroom though that's carol
lombard's place but yes that's like so
there's that um
now this place too and i don't know if
they still do this or not but they do a
haunted lockdown
so you can get locked in the saloon from
midnight to 4 a.m
and see if you have like any ghosts and
they like provide like you got to pay
obviously but they provide like booze
and food and all that kind of stuff that
sounds kind of fun actually i don't give
a [ __ ] if there's like any ghosts or not
but i don't know that just sounds like a
fun situation if you had like a bunch of
people going with you that
you know you could like get all
about ghost stories and all that kind of
stuff i think that'd be kind of neat
so all right here's another one from new
york city new york new york the ear inn
now this is one of the oldest bars in
new york city uh apron opened in 1817
uh and the building of the bar was
actually it's called the james brown
house not that james brown uh it's much
older
and it's a designated historic landmark
so the original building was built in
1770 for james brown obviously uh he was
an ex-slave and was actually an aide to
george washington during the
revolutionary war
and this is the house that he uh went to
like after he retired that he had built
after he retired
so he died in somewhere in the mid-1800s
and after that like his house kind of
became other things but it was mostly
like um just a bar now it didn't really
have a name interestingly
they pretty much i mean they kind of i
feel like they brewed their own beer and
whiskey
and then it was like a big hangout for
sailors because the um the hudson river
was like right there so they had like
all these sailors coming in so like i
said they didn't have a name for the
place it wasn't like a business business
i guess it was just kind of like hey we
got some beer so everybody just came in
there
and one the thing one of the things that
brought a lot of people in which
actually is like a pretty good uh
business model i guess for back in the
day
is if the sailors would come in and they
would buy booze then they would feed you
for free so
obviously like a lot of sailors are like
woo that sounds like a good situation
you just like pay for a few beers or
whatever and you also get like a good
meal and everything like that so that
was like a pretty winning formula so the
place was like [ __ ]
packed and like became like really
really popular
so uh so when time went on though
uh the place eventually turned into a
restaurant um but
during prohibition like it's still like
it sold booze as a restaurant obviously
but during prohibition um it just
you know went into a speakeasy like a
lot of places did back then it's like oh
we totally don't have alcohol in here
but you can go in the back and like get
it so it was just that kind of stuff
um also just like many uh other
establishments of this type of the time
period the upstairs was also a brothel
but they had some other stuff too they
had like a doctor's office up there and
like you could stay up there like it was
a boarding house they had that kind of
stuff but the main level was mostly just
like you know a restaurant at a bar
pretty much
now after prohibition uh it reopened to
the public it still didn't have a name
like i said
so uh by this time the place had been
there for such a long time and had such
a really good reputation like with well
not a good reputation but a reputation
uh with sailors and stuff um and it was
a place where it was kind of one of
those places where like they don't give
a [ __ ] what you do in there you know
what i mean so it was kind of like a
more notorious i guess than famous
because you could go there and do all
kind of like illegal stuff and nobody
would do anything like you could gamble
and whatnot uh so and like i said it was
known as kind of like a sailor's hangout
so they what are you doing to spock he's
[ __ ] rape and spock leaving him he's
[ __ ] alone
bless you he's an alien okay you're
sneezing too huh
it's not that dusty over there
well she's what's the matter
what does he matter
she's just right here she's right here
what's the matter baby girl she's like
what is going on i want to get up and
shut up brian
brian says he loves the show we love you
too bro oh
yeah i'm just laughing about i'm still
laughing at rebecca saying i hate public
bathrooms i do too it's like i don't
know why you'd want a hot one if you
could choose it
i mean gross but you know whatever you
do you i'm not i'm not judging but uh so
yeah they're saying that deborah harry
liked that book of sugar oh she did she
liked that booze too
yeah why not both i think sophie said
she saw
debbie just a couple months ago and she
said she was so drunk she couldn't
[ __ ] sing that people were just kind
of laughing it off at her show off but
yeah she gets [ __ ] loaded
there's some uh
there's some videos of her on youtube
[ __ ] you know it's just as like later
years like you know past couple years
you know at hotels doing [ __ ] she's
rapture
and she's [ __ ] up she's like what i
thought
she told me
whatever
i can't remember yeah
she's [ __ ]
she probably sounds like me at the end
of the show
[Laughter]
but the thing well she's debbie [ __ ]
hairy all right it's just like she's
like look i was like right here at the
forefront of puck rock it's like i'm an
old lady now and i don't give a [ __ ]
what anybody thinks anymore i respect
that i respect that game yeah
she look my ex looked like a strange
mixer of debbie harry in some photos and
other photos she looked like chrissy
hines which are totally two opposite
women but
i think it's just chrissy hind without
she has
h y and d okay yeah without she also
looks a little bit like christy hines
sometimes i don't i don't actually
remember
i mean i know you had pictures of her
and i've seen her but i don't exactly
remember she looked like sometimes she
reminded me of of either one depending
on what the expression on her face i got
to get more booze i don't look like
anybody except me you just like you
i think i've said this the only person
that and this is i don't know why i
remember this so so clearly the only
time that anyone has ever told me that i
looked like anybody in particular was
back when i was in junior high or maybe
like the early years of high school
and a guy told me
that i looked like that little redheaded
girl
in the um
that art of noise video close to the
edit
i was like random okay i mean you have
to think this was the 80s so it wasn't
like as random as it is nowadays but
so it's like every time we were at
eyebar a couple or barbarella i guess a
couple weeks ago and they played that
song and it's like every time i hear
that song and like see that video i'm
just kind of like some guy like back in
the old days like told me i look like
that i don't think i do but whatever but
you have to think like i actually do
have red hair like in real life in real
life
i diet in real life but my natural hair
color is red so i did actually have red
hair like up until i was in my 30s
so yes where was i okay so uh
so this place got got a good reputation
uh among sailors at least like hey you
can just go there and boo and like i
said it was another brothel you go there
you can drink all you want and then you
get free food and there's hookers and
it's super fun hey pookie i see you back
there
and like i said it didn't have an
official name
so what they called it was the green
door because obviously it had a green
door that would be pretty weird if it
had a red door and they called it the
green door so now i'm kind of wondering
if that kind of famous that was like
kind of a famous porn movie right behind
the green door wasn't it and didn't the
cramps write a song about that but um so
maybe they took it from this because
this place is like kind of famous so
they just started calling it the green
door that wasn't its name but that's
just what they call it because it had a
green door
and uh so then
the late 1970s i kind of love this story
i don't know why
so the late 1970s uh the guys that took
it over
they decided that after all this time
the place had been there for [ __ ] 100
years at this point and they're like
we're we're finally gonna give this
place an official name
and they decided to call it the ear in
because all they did what i mean it just
had like the neon sign out front that
said just said bar on it because it
didn't have a name so they said what
they did was they just kind of like
knocked out the um
the lights like the neon tubes like on
one side of the bee so that they didn't
come on so it looked like it said ear
and they're like well that worked out
pretty well because i guess they owned
like a music magazine which was also
called ear so we're like we're just
going to call it the ear in and they did
that like to kind of circumvent
some laws because they didn't want to
have to like go through all the [ __ ]
paperwork that you'd have to go through
to like you know get like a formal
change of signage so they were just kind
of like well yeah it's that it's bar
unless you want it to be
ear in which case either one they just
didn't want to have to jump through all
the hoops
so uh so yeah there was that
now this place uh has a bunch of ghost
stories attached to it as any place does
that have this kind of reputation or
been around for this long
now it's probably its most famous ghost
is just called
mickey the sailor
now mickey the sailor uh used to come
there all the time when he was alive
and uh when he wasn't away at sea he
pretty much spent all of his time and
his money there
and the story goes that he loved this
place so much
that every time he was there and they
were gonna close it down he would beg
the staff to please stay open so he
could just stay there
all the time he just never wanted to
leave it was like [ __ ] cheers in that
way i guess
now nobody knows exactly
when mickey died
um
one of the stories
is that he had been away at sea for a
long time and then he's like oh my god i
need some booze
so
he
runs into
the the ear in or the green door or
whatever the hell you want to call it
and he's just kind of like oh my god i
need a drink right now and they said he
was like frothing at the mouth and
everything like he really he really
wanted some he was a drunk you guys
so uh he apparently
had been uh so deprived at sea that he
just kept drinking and drinking and
drinking
until he died of alcohol poisoning yeah
uh and that this that story says that he
actually like died on the bar stool
uh and that his ghost just like kind of
stayed there
so it's like he just like sits at the
bar like well at least he died happy he
died doing what he loved he's like you
know what i love this place so i'm just
gonna drink a drink until i die and then
my ghost is just gonna sit here on this
bar stool and i'm just gonna like say i
was like that's kind of sweet
isn't it i think i don't know
um okay so that's one theory i that's i
i like that one i i'm gonna say it's i
don't know i think that's kind of i
think that's kind of cute
but i mean it's not cute that he died of
alcohol poisoning if that dude died but
well what he's a vampire he's still
alive
okay it's not just a legend
well i don't know i don't know nobody
like i said he knows right yeah he's a
legendary dude yeah i think he's a
lizard
because i said if he died yeah yeah
that's the way you did it well everybody
dies i'm just saying it's like you know
if that dude existed yeah certainly uh
so the other theory is that mickey
actually didn't uh die like didn't
wasn't away at sea
but he was actually at the bar in 1920
and was just doing his normal [ __ ]
and then he decided uh for whatever
reason that he's gonna go to his actual
house which you know unprecedented and
um
as he sort of like drunkenly staggered
out of the bar he got hit by a car
and died man we got 40 people and that's
a huge audience for this show
wow yeah okay yeah thank you for showing
up
so i mean this story is probably more
likely but
not as fun i just kind of like the idea
that he just drank himself to death on
the stool and then his ghost just stayed
there
you know what i mean like they took his
body away and his spirit remained and
he's just like i'm just gonna i'm good
i'm just gonna stay right here you know
what i mean
the fact of him just like drinking and
then being like bye you guys i'm gonna
go home for a change and then like and
then he gets hit by a car i'm like ah
that's kind of depressing i don't like
that
um but i mean he they still say he
haunts the bar but even though he died
outside like getting hit by a car but i
don't know i i like the alcohol
poisoning theory better um so basically
the story goes that mickey uh however he
died is still haunting the [ __ ]
now he um
ow sorry are you kicking me yeah god
damn senate is getting stoned listening
to your tell stories listen to jenny
tell us
so what he does um is
in the afterlife
which is maybe not so cute he's decided
he's become going to become like a
sexual
predator so
the waitresses walk by and he takes his
little cold ghost hands and like pokes
at him or like grabs their butts and
stuff like that
also um
women that have actually stayed in the
inn because i said there's like an in
upstairs like you know we're like a
little hotel kind of situation
and women that have stayed up there said
sometimes they'll wake up and there's
somebody like in bed with them but they
don't see so mickey's the go he's being
kind of like so like i said maybe not so
cute okay look i want to show you guys a
photo this is from patrick
all right patrick oh [ __ ] patrick is
making a couple of braces he's going to
sell and he goes thanks for the info
inspiration guys
[ __ ] uh he's prepping for 13 o'clock
and this is where they're they're little
necklaces that say i love bubology i
love bubology yeah it's gonna be like
for him and his uh his girlfriend
all right i love booboo
[ __ ] that's a shirt that i should make i
should make like uh well i should make
an institute of boobology yeah sure
yeah or maybe and actually oh i should
make you a business card yeah tom ross
institute of biology there's patrick
okay
john gore said was mars bar in new york
city covered yet i didn't do that one
i've been there though
but i didn't know it was supposed to be
haunted
he said that place had to be haunted i
kind of feel like everywhere in new york
city's probably haunted i've been there
a bunch of times but it's like i never
like i said i've never really
experienced like any kind of like
haunted yeah your poltergeist stuff and
everything like that but that's not
really the same thing i've never seen
any ghosts i've never there's patrick's
cute goth girl
so there's his girlfriend sushi that's
right she loves bubology too did i get
the glasses in she got the cute little
round glasses
okay
yeah everybody's getting started well
that's good everybody's going to stop
that well that takes some pressure off
me yeah
that's okay
i'm gonna tell i'm gonna tell people i
worry too much about i worry too much
about it i'm just trying to have a good
time you know what i mean yeah but yeah
so
drunk ass mickey now that he's like a
ghost and he's probably like well you
know like nobody can mace me or like
punch me in the dick or something like
that so he's just gonna go around like
grabbing ladies like with his little
cold ghost hands [ __ ] that [ __ ]
ghosts
yeah
um also oh another thing that they say
he does
is because he's a drunk
he'll also when you're not looking uh
drink out of your drink
like somebody they're watching [ __ ]
featuring us on the show
look we love you too man yeah that's all
the good ones i love that i love you
need to get deeper into the science of
[ __ ] booboology okay uh it's it's not
only is a science it's an art too it's
an art form you know i mean it's not
quick
you know what bubology is
when you see it okay it's hard to define
i think that you should
a research
[Laughter]
you should do like a kind of a study in
boobology and i think you should wear
some boobs
and get some boobs from and go out any
store that yeah and you should like go
out in the field and like measure
people's like reactions
to
your boobage
man let's just stop this [ __ ] [ __ ]
santa just said i'm an ass man sorry tom
yeah it's all good it's all part of the
[ __ ] tom's an ass man too well
actually thomas are pretty much
everything i like everything you like i
like your ass yeah i don't fixate that
much it's a holistic thing
i like it all but i like everything
except feet i don't like feet
[Laughter]
most feet aren't any good
it's very rare that you see some feet
that are [ __ ] cute
i have acceptable feet yeah yeah your
ears are pretty good yes you got pretty
good the only feet that [ __ ] stand
out is being [ __ ] like oh those are
outstanding feet it's usually on a girl
she's really short and they're [ __ ]
tiny
you know what i'm talking about yeah i
mean she wait she's 4 11. and she's
short she's got little [ __ ] short
stubby looking little feet i think
that's kind of cute but in general feet
aren't that good
and a lot of a lot of these supermodel
looking chicks they have fantastic
figures tall
you know tall build the faces look great
you look at their feet big old long feet
you know what i mean well i mean
generally people that are tall generally
you generally have bigger feet yeah i
mean that's just how that's going to
work
it's very rare that you see kind of like
a tall person with little bitty feet
yeah because you'd follow it's just kind
of funny you know to me you know
it's just something yeah
i don't know i never really like i don't
i don't feel one way or the other about
feet i mean you know i just don't look
at you there's nothing that's much
better i got it necessary i got a shoe
fetish she does have a little bit woman
plus shoe is much better than woman
without a shoe
but it's not so bad like i said this
many times whenever i mention my shoe
fetish i don't have it so bad that i
don't need the woman they got
so bad
that they don't even need the woman they
just want the shoe
i can't understand that i at least had
to have the women in there somewhere
yeah yeah
yeah well yeah well you only like the
shoe in the context of yeah it being
worn right that's she's not so much
right that shoe really isn't anything
without that woman you know but they got
dudes that have it so bad they don't
even need the woman they just need the
shoe yeah
i gotta laugh at that
hey they're not hurting anybody i gotta
laugh at that if they want to order some
used shoes off ebay and sniff them then
i'm just you know whatever i don't even
think they're smelling the shoes it's
the shape well yeah that to you but well
some people smell them
maybe i guess uh
i don't know i don't know what those
[ __ ] do
i never really
was interested in smelling anything i
just [ __ ] just i just thought the
shoe
i don't well i'm not doing anything to
explain this [ __ ] to you people i just
look i'm trying to wait you got into it
there's just i just like the shoe i mean
you brought it up i like that
i'm too drunk
you do that a lot of people the woman
has the shoe on it's much better
especially when you get drunk you kind
of like you bring up like a topic and
then you go off on it and then i start
talking about and then you like and then
you get on you and then you yell at me
like so like i didn't even bring that up
that was you that started that yeah like
talking about the shoes
you know what i mean i was just talking
about well like what a chest or the
molester this [ __ ] mickey the ghost
is
like grabbing people and like i said
he's probably like oh i'm dead i can get
away with it you know what i mean okay
fine
like sneaking into bed with like living
ladies like get the [ __ ] out of my bed
mickey the ghost god damn it
um and like i said oh another thing that
he they said he does is like he said
he'll steal your drinks right yeah
that's right people give it give the
show a big thumbs up yeah super chap sir
super chats are active if you all are
enjoying the show
uh we would [ __ ] up you
should i would love it if you'd show the
appreciation i'm passing around the
collection plate to give jenny a tip for
the hard work she's done today to do
this entertainment this entertaining
show writing down all these damn [ __ ]
notes and everything this girl's working
hard go ahead and give us a super chat
people give us a super chat i'll make
her pop her titties out
don't promise that no we can't do it
i'm lying it'll never happen [ __ ]
youtube will pull the [ __ ] channel
that's what i'm saying i can't do that
it just sounded cool it sounded cool it
sounded cool
people are like hey
now they're going to sue us yeah like i
didn't get what i paid for god damn it
no
yeah so yeah so this [ __ ] like i
said it won't even like pinch your it's
not bad enough that he'll like pinch
your girlfriend's butt or whatever but
he'll also like drink your [ __ ] so they
said that a lot of things a lot of times
people like order a drink and like put
it down on the table and then like turn
their back or something they'll turn
back around and like all the shit's gone
like most of it's gone and they said
that a lot of uh fights like break out
at the bar because they're like their
friend like you [ __ ] should you drink
my [ __ ] like when i was back was turned
but apparently like the ghost is doing
it i don't know if i buy that or not but
you know it's a fun story anyway
so so yeah there's kind of like this
whole uh thing about that like him
drinking your [ __ ]
now uh apparently what happened here too
was that
i guess this guy has been seen like this
ghost has been seen at some point there
was um a story in 2014
and a waitress that worked at the bar
her and her boyfriend had actually been
staying in one of the rooms upstairs
and she woke up in the middle of the
night and her she said her boyfriend was
like staring into the corner like
you know really intensely focused on
something and she's like what the [ __ ]
are you looking at and he said i'm just
saying hello to the strange man standing
in the corner damn which
man if i woke up in the middle of the
night and you said that to me i'd
probably like wet my pants that was
that's creepy that's creepy
but uh yeah so yeah
they don't know if that was mickey or
not but that seems like that's kind of
like the ghost that everybody like talks
about so yeah so that was the ear in uh
in new york city a short walk from
greenwich village so if you want to go
there and check it out then that's where
it is
white horse tavern
newport rhode island
now this is the oldest tavern in rhode
island and the oldest continually
operating tavern in the united states
and the 10th oldest tavern in the whole
entire world
opened in
1673. so uh this is actually uh is a
national historic landmark
now it was actually uh originally built
as a house for a person named francis
brinley in 1652
and was transformed into a tavern as i
mentioned in 1673.
so a bunch of like different because
it's a tavern and back in those days uh
you know all the kind of councils and
stuff like that would always meet at you
know taverns and coffee houses and
whatnot so you know there's a lot of
like uh local politics going on there as
well
now one of the stories about this place
was that in the 1700s there was a guy
who
mysteriously died in one of the second
floor rooms of the tavern now
conveniently nobody knew what the guy's
name was or where he came from or how he
died although they think that he maybe
died of smallpox which was uh you know
pretty common around that time
and uh for many decades after that
people who came to the bar or stayed at
the inn would start saying that they saw
this guy who was like dressed in
colonial looking clothes hanging out by
one of the fireplaces and
also haunting the men's bathroom
what is with these ghosts and bathrooms
man you're trying to make some money
you know
some of these dudes you know what i mean
now every time i go to a public bathroom
in a place i'm going to be like is there
ghosts in here
they got dudes out there that are so
[ __ ] hard up they want to [ __ ] uh
go hang out in the men's room trying to
make a few dollars you know
this is sad even when they say even when
they're a ghost yeah and they're
straight too they can go well just need
money so bad we don't know if they're
straight or not well they need 350 years
they need the money so bad that the they
did they're going cape or pay yeah gave
her bait they're gonna suck suck for a
payday
that's what they're doing
i don't know pretending to be gay i
don't know how much suction you could
get as a ghost
what are the physics of decisions
metaphysical i think too much about this
kind of stuff you're thinking yeah
why i think it's so much this is [ __ ]
dumb [ __ ] that i [ __ ] say
out of the [ __ ] blue
[Laughter]
but because but because what you doing
here you're taking
excuse me sir
are you are you okay wait are we talking
about a real dude or a ghost dude both
he's alive and dead at the same time
like excuse me schrodinger's battles
excuse me sir and i said how are you
doing man what's up mrs anything i can
do for you what do you mean do you need
some toilet paper
what you do and i'll look at him like
your hands clean and he's like yeah
that's it go ahead and shake it for me
[Laughter]
so okay him in a towel over there go
ahead wipe it
hold on
get that i don't want it to fall in the
pants
you're doing that kind of [ __ ] you know
how about are you going to give them a
tip
yeah is it a ghost tip
no real you could just like pretend that
it's mine
that was a lot of money back when that
ghost was alive
he's probably like holy crap i wish i
could hold on to it and i wasn't just
made of exoplasma that's 75 cents
oh my god
like well like i said i think a lot
about these kind of things because i
kind of feel like
people that are really into these ghost
stories which i am too i really like
them too but
i'm kind of like i'm an overthinking
[ __ ] so every time like somebody
just has some kind of like little detail
like hey here's this ghost that haunts
the men's bathroom
i have questions like i i imagine like a
whole scenario i'm like well what about
this and what about that like i have a
whole like thing that goes on like when
you say something like that you know
and it was just kind of like when you
say something that's just kind of like
an off the cuff sort of thing but then
but then it spawns this whole
uh
it's it's like a fractal and it kind of
like erupts in my mind and i think of
like all these possible scenarios yeah
we need to write a book together
you know what i mean and i'm just kind
of like well yeah but what about this
and what about and what about what if
that situation happens and like then
what you know what i mean i'm just
thinking about the men's room and a dude
trying to [ __ ] shake my dick forget
the last drops out that's all you know
you want to read into it too much you
know what i mean it's just
it's just 70 well that well that's why
his hands were not his hands were clean
it was all right it's like like a
medical procedure well his hands were
ghostly
so you don't know if they were clean or
not because maybe cleanliness doesn't
apply in the ghost world it's like the
doctor grabbing your nuts and [ __ ]
making you cough and [ __ ] that's all it
is it's like that you don't want to take
it personally
you're not trying to make his money
you know
it's a royal treatment you know
[Laughter]
john gore said the bathroom attendant
thing is a strange tradition always made
me nervous god i hate that yeah honestly
i've only encountered that
yeah and i'm like if i got it it's a
gift
yeah of course you don't need anybody i
mean i've had that have like a couple
times like i think when we were at that
like horror convention and like you go
in the bathroom there what next time i
see a bathroom attendant i'm gonna be in
the urinal taking a piss i'm gonna have
to do it i'm gonna ask the dude say your
hair's clean
yeah it's cause it's usually a big old
black dude your hair's clean
come over here and hold this for me
try to beat my ass probably
what what did it say 95 of the public
bathrooms in america
people can
are absolutely fine going to the
bathroom and washing their hands and
getting their own towels yeah like last
time i saw that [ __ ] remember the last
time we saw that [ __ ] thank you next
dimension media hey guys great show
tonight thank you very much thank you
talking about
bathroom ghosts bathroom ghosts
last time i saw the bathroom attendant
that was at um
remember that goth club that was at the
[ __ ] sports bar owned by the [ __ ]
pro
basketball player yeah yeah the pro
football player that's right and that
and and tina and oh that's right i
forgot they had a bathroom attack
that was a long time i'll back up and
tell you the story
dj friend of ours and his wife [ __ ]
found this venue
they sell dj now at mannequins what's
that yeah they've been dj in the
mannequins now
we've known them forever
so we start promoting for this new night
and it's at a sports bar
it was formerly
a sports bar that had pretty much
an expressly black clientele
the owner was a black dude who was a
football player who's a pro football
player
they had a shooting out down in the
place though and [ __ ] he vacated it
he says i'm out of this business i
[ __ ] met the dude i don't know i
don't i'm not into sports ball i i don't
give a [ __ ] who he was but he had a lot
of money big [ __ ] dude
he said i'm out of here my lease is up
and [ __ ] some rod you know some odd
months and you guys [ __ ] you know
keep this place busy
until i can check out
that place had a [ __ ]
bathroom attendant in it yeah
i forgot from that era
they were trying to sell whole bottles
of sure remember
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah they were
trying to have vip tables and sell whole
bottles of shirach and do [ __ ] like you
do in the r b in the [ __ ] rap crowd
that [ __ ] doesn't fly with the [ __ ]
gotham i'm like we're all broke we all
know each other how are we gonna stunt
on one another
we all grew up together
mean you're trying you know
a [ __ ] like that people like [ __ ]
knock it off you're not a vip [ __ ] i
[ __ ] like whatever you think you are
yeah we're all vips in here you know
it's like there's something to that you
know i've seen you puke in a pool in the
parking lot right stop
it it's funny
but that went on for a while and it's
just like the whole vip angle never
worked in a goth club at all well we
don't really have the same have that i
mean that's not like a thing that we do
in that culture there was a night where
we were at [ __ ] uh southern knights
which is a [ __ ] great [ __ ] goth
and [ __ ] club
that we had a goth night going it's a
drag bar they yeah it was like it was
mostly like a god it's almost like a
finish night really the place was great
we loved it that's a nice place it had a
theater in it it looks like a dump from
the outside but it's beautiful you go in
there man it's a [ __ ] paradise it's
gorgeous it had a bunch of bars it looks
tropical and like the back patio was
beautiful patios
couple of dance floors and had a theater
in it yeah
and uh we had some porn stars in there
one time and they tried to play the
[ __ ] vip area guess who was in the
vip vip area the porn stars yeah
hi nobody gives a [ __ ] about that
you know it's just [ __ ] funny there's
like whatever we're just like yeah
everybody in this [ __ ] is a
well-known scenester we're all vips okay
[ __ ]
just funny you know well that's what i
mean
with us well yeah i mean we've got the
vegan black metal chef [ __ ]
that have been on [ __ ] abc news
people that have written books [ __ ]
all kinds of cam girls that have done
all kinds of [ __ ] and [ __ ] people
that have been in the scene for [ __ ]
ever and g djs and [ __ ]
everybody in the goddamn club is a vip
yeah people in bands and stuff i kind of
feel like most of the people like it
seems like 80 90 of the people are some
kind of some kind of they're not like
famous but they they're creators yeah
they're artists or djs or musicians or
something like so and you know some of
them have like a pretty substantial
following as well man i gotta get back
into southern nights
it's still there it's still there we
could i wonder what that place is doing
there should be something like i said
it's you know it's a gay club it's
probably one it's i think it's the kind
of the best one yeah i mean that i've
been to i've been a couple other ones
that were good but that one is kind of
like the [ __ ] gay club but every night
was its own specific night
on on the goth nights there it was goth
and fetish
it's the same crowd as anywhere else i
wasn't a gay night it was called escape
we called it yeah that was the name of
the night yeah
and we had and all the bartenders were
[ __ ] they loved it
they [ __ ] loved our night they
thought it was great
because you know they were like you
straight people are okay
well well some streams well yeah it's a
mix
it's a mixture i wouldn't go as far as
to say all straight people are yeah
okay but from their point of view we
were straight yeah yeah
but we're not like
you weren't regular we're not like
regular straight people right yeah
so they're like oh you guys are right
you're right
so you know but yeah i missed that place
i know i really did like that place
actually it's a nice venue like i said
and it's weird because it looks like it
looks like a dump from the outside yeah
it doesn't really look like anything
from the outside it's not even like in a
place that where there's a lot of clubs
it's like in the middle of nowhere it's
like underneath an overpass and then
there's like a [ __ ] insurance yeah
like
across the officer and a cheap motel so
that might come in handy yeah i mean but
there's like nothing around there that's
what i'm saying there's no other clubs
or anything like that
but it was just like in the middle of it
but it was like [ __ ] world class you
know what i mean yeah it's a world-class
caliber you went in there and you're
like man this place is [ __ ] nice
and uh you know it was it was a
playground for the underground it'd be a
good way to put it you could have any
kind of event there and you'd have a lot
of privacy
well again it's one of those places and
that's what i like about barbarella's
new location
is that because it's not
in an area where there's a bunch of
other clubs where you're gonna get a
bunch of just like walk in yeah there's
no walking i mean you have to go there
specifically you can't just like walk
there right you have to drive there and
you have to know there's nothing else
around right where you would go
everything else around there like i said
it's just cheap ass insurance offices
and stuff like that everything's closed
so it's kind of like that and that's
where the new barbarella is too it's
like you have to specifically go there
the new barbarelles is going to be good
once it's done that would make a
fantastic holy [ __ ] the last memento
mori that we went to
they could not believe how many people
like the owners like we talked to john
and lorraine and um they're like we
can't believe like how many people
came to it it was the first one that
they'd done on a friday night yeah they
only have one bartender now yeah uh and
one bar she couldn't stay up with it and
she went and there was like a huge line
like all night yeah and the dan and the
dance floor was just like packed there
was no room it was [ __ ] packed yeah
and they couldn't believe it they
couldn't i couldn't believe it like how
many people came out i don't know if
it's gonna be like that like every night
but it was it was very successful
underground scenes
be it
goth or
something or
drag or whatever
you want that privacy you don't want
just random people walking in and i told
john i said john this would make a
fantastic fetish club and he's like yeah
you think so yeah
you can have like fetish parties yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah sure
fetish [ __ ] thing happened here this
place would be great who should i do
that's just because there's nothing
you've got dimitri dimitri knows all
about that [ __ ] you know but we'll
see
that's just gonna target market it that
place the best thing about that place is
it's nice it's brand new and it's
[ __ ] hidden in in the warehouse
district like the old rave scene
yeah but it was nice and honestly it
doesn't even have the thing about and i
don't know if they're going to
change this in the future but it doesn't
even have any signage no it doesn't have
any signage telling you that
it's like in a warehouse like in the
factory district and you have to know a
warehouse it's in a sports like a sports
center yeah that was in the warehouse
district yeah but you have to go there
there's no sign no there's no nothing
and there's a huge parking
so you just have to like know where it's
at there's no way some random
motherfucker's just going to walk in
because there's nothing around nothing
everything's closed it's all it's a it's
a warehouse like it's an industrial park
yeah and what and you could when you
have a situation like that
what the girls are wearing gets wilder
and wilder because they know they don't
have to worry about some person coming
off the street that doesn't well it's
safe it's safe
i mean the thing when we were there
friday night there was a jillion people
there but we knew
everybody or knew somebody that knew
everybody so it's like a huge private
party yeah
yeah which is nice right it's nice not
to have to worry about it i didn't worry
about it that much
um at eibar like downtown but
going to and from the place was always a
little
fraught i will say yeah so we're
plugging the place now you can look it
up on on [ __ ] uh google
it's called barbarella's orlando it's on
john young parkway john young parkway
because i think some places still have
the old address which is downtown but
it's yeah the downtown address is gone a
lot of photos on that on that google ad
or that are from the old from the old
place the new place doesn't quite look
like that but it looks as good they're
still putting more lights up and they're
making it bigger and bigger the place
can be as big
as three tennis courts that's how big
that place is in there they actually had
to wall it off to make it smaller so
you're not spread out so far
it's huge in there
and it's air conditioned and it's got
bathrooms it's [ __ ] great brand new
looking
it's good yeah i feel like it hasn't
been there that long no whatever i mean
there were some kind of fitness thing
they were doing badminton in there
during the day but he's just doing it at
night in there yeah
yeah that's the thing it was yeah it was
like a big sports center like a big yeah
he's got a liquor license but he can't
use it because it doesn't meet code yet
so everything has to be in cans or
bottles
so they have a
bacardi in the cans and
oh and did we get another uh super chat
no no yeah i said that's
yeah okay
well i'm gonna go back to ghost for a
second i mean i mean technically we were
talking about bars so that's kind of
like half what we were supposed to be
talking about although like i said i've
never been to like a bar that was i've
been to bars that were supposed to be
haunted but i've never like experienced
anything i've never experienced anything
like haunting so except in a big lot one
time and i don't think that i would call
that a haunting i just felt like weird
and like i had to get out of there i
didn't see a ghost or nothing
but so yeah we again got distracted by
a ghost haunting a bathroom because i i
just don't know why i don't know why so
many ghosts want to hold the bathrooms
but okay i wouldn't want to i you know
i'm not a verse like if i could haunt
some [ __ ] i totally would but
i'm not gonna hang out in the [ __ ]
bathroom why the [ __ ] would you want to
do that so yeah so this place other than
having this colonial looking dude
hanging out in the bathroom which yeah
that'd be a little weird um also uh
there's a female ghost wandering around
the tavern uh who hangs out by the
fireplace and also uh some people have
reported hearing a young girl crying
uh you know disembodied like even though
there are no kids in the place
uh so there's that
and uh also kind of people feeling hands
on their shoulders [ __ ] like that uh you
know
now let's talk about going over to the
uk for a little while because we've
talked about some places in the us
so this place in london and it's called
the grenadier
now this building was originally built
in 1720
and was originally the officer's mess
for the senior infantry regiment of his
majesty's army
and this was a a regiment that was uh
instrumental in defeating napoleon at
waterloo so after that battle
they changed their name to the grenadier
guards
so when the tavern like you know they
kind of like used it as that for a while
but then it got repurposed into a tavern
and then they first named it the
guardsman that was in 1818
and a lot of the people that hung out
there were from that regiment still
because that was uh their barracks were
nearby so that was kind of like their
local place they would go and drink
so uh
so after that though like because of all
these people that came there they
eventually changed the name to the
grenadier because they were called the
grenadier guards
now the interesting thing about this
place it's kind of a little bit out of
the way so some kind of famous people
like the duke of wellington uh king
george the
fourth um
used to stop by there every now and then
like to get a drink because it was a
little bit out of the way
now they also have uh so they kind of
had it it was kind of like a a situation
where like upstairs that was kind of
like where the fancier people went and
then like the more broke-ass people were
kind of like down in the cellar
so you know so the poorer people be down
there like drinking playing cards now
the story goes that one oh there's pokey
she's like what put me down put me down
yeah you wanna be on the show yeah you
wanna be on a show you wanna say
something
no she's doing [ __ ] no she's saying no i
don't wanna say nothing i don't wanna
say nothing oh you're so cute folk
uh but yeah so back in 1818 it was
september one evening
and there was a young grenadier guard
named cedric
and he was actually caught cheating at
cards
and uh this seems like a little bit of
an overreaction gonna say
uh but his
the guys he was playing cards with got
so mad that he was cheating
that they beat the [ __ ] out of him
and he died
over a card game settle down possible i
mean yeah i'm sure it happens and i'm
sure everybody was like drinking yeah so
i'm sure that didn't help
but money might have been involved i
mean
i mean i guess it must have been must
have been yeah
can you imagine it's like they're just
in there playing crazy eights or
whatever and like like crazy stealing
everybody uno
or something like that yeah spit in the
ocean so they're just like they're
playing that and then like i'm saying
you cedric you [ __ ]
that was
that was his name his name was cedric
just like one of those like medieval
nights or something like that and he's
he's cheating and i don't even know if
he was cheating allegedly he was
cheating and they just like beat him to
death so you know that's like i said
listen a little bit seems a little bit
like
overkill now uh even though cedric had
been beaten to death allegedly uh in
this area
uh his ghost apparently decided it was
going to hang out there i don't know
because despite or because he's not
allowed to leave i don't really know so
he hangs out at this place
now they said they see him all the time
but usually he starts acting up more in
september which is right around when he
was killed like in real life right
so
uh and a lot of people have seen him too
they said they said they just see him
he's kind of like just moves or he never
makes any noise or anything like that he
just kind of like moves through the
rooms and they said it's like super
super creepy and he looks kind of like
bummed out
um also there's some poltergeist
activity too uh objects disappearing or
moved around during the night uh the
tables and chairs rattle stuff like that
um a lot of people hear footsteps when
nobody's in there that kind of stuff uh
and also people have heard like moaning
sounds coming from the cellar when
nobody's down there
and some of the rooms in the pub are
super super cold and they said sometimes
that can linger like you know what i
mean it's not just thing where ooh like
cold draft there like sometimes it's
cold for like hours or days at a time so
there's that whole thing too
and uh here's one story
now uh i found this on a site somewhere
it says like the chief superintendent
from the new scotland yard i don't know
what year this was
he was uh in the grenadier one night
and he was having a drink in there uh
and he notices like puffs of smoke kind
of swirling around
so he which he kind of like reaches out
to see like where the smoke is coming
from
and
something burned him like he was like
that like what the [ __ ] is all the smoke
and he's like ow god damn it uh he'd
been burned by a cigarette but there was
nobody there so it was like the ghost
was like sitting there smoking but then
like the cigarette was real so yeah
that's one story
uh there was another event too that
happened uh fairly recently and this was
a guy who worked at the bar
and he went down into the cellar to get
some cigars to bring back up
and when he was down there he said [ __ ]
it i'm gonna stop and have a cigarette
so he just like stops have a little
cigarette break
and then he said that the the landlord
had a cat and uh the landlord's cat was
in the cellar and he said that was a
little bit weird because the cat wasn't
actually the cat lived in the flat like
over the pub where the owner lived and
wasn't allowed to like run around in the
bar
uh but suddenly the cat was down there
and he said while he was down there like
the cellar got like really really cold
and his ashtray that he was using for
his uh you know cigarette break flew
across the room and hit the wall i'm
assuming it broke it was made of crystal
and then he said the cat started
freaking out like it bowed up like that
and bit um his ankle like and went like
lashed on his ankle like that and bit
into his ankle it would he said that
never usually happened so he's basically
okay what the [ __ ] so he shakes the cat
off and runs up the stairs and that he
said that was like super super weird
now this particular place like i said
it's in london i'm assuming it's still
there but
uh i've seen pictures of it they said
it's really really hard to find if you
don't know exactly where it is because
it's not this is kind of surrounded by
like little cottages
and you have to kind of go through all
these little like cobblestone lanes and
all this kind of stuff and private
alleys and streets and stuff and then
you'll find it um and it's under this
big tree
but it's kind of cool looking but like i
said if you don't know where it is it's
kind of a place where you have to find
it but yeah uh another thing that i
thought was kind of interesting about
this remember cedric the guy that got
beaten to death over the over the
cheating at cards yeah
um
what they do at this place
there's a room in the pub that is the
ceiling is all uh pound notes you know
which actually they don't have over
there anymore they're all coins now but
back in the old days they used to have
like one pound notes like we have one
dollars you know and the whole ceiling
has them and what you're supposed to do
people put them up there to pay cedric
the ghost's gambling debts yeah and
that's supposed to keep the ghost from
like [ __ ] with you is you're supposed
to like give him a pound so you like
kind of like staple it or like stick it
to the ceiling so there's like a whole
like so now the whole ceiling is like
pound notes because they're they're
trying to like pay the ghost game like
that's which i thought that was kind of
cool
all right i'm having a drink and i have
to go to the bathroom too okay
so talk about that okay jenny with her
cute little feet my cute feet yes you
got cute little feet she's running i do
have they're very small cute yeah
look at that booty okay
yeah i'm looking at the booty here
okay
so i'm gonna give another commercial
uh for
i have a new twitch channel
on twitch
it's called tom 13 o'clock it's all
lowercase there's no apostrophe
friend me over there follow me on twitch
i'll be playing video games during the
day
okay
um got my new headset so i'll be talking
you guys can ask me questions we can
talk about whatever you want
i'm doing
tomb raider legend
okay classic laura croft
then i'll be doing um anniversary two
tomb raider anniversary it's another
good game
and then uh after that i'm gonna do tomb
raider underworld which is a more a more
sophisticated game on a different engine
i also might jump into some other [ __ ] i
might do a little bit of metal gear if
i'm [ __ ] really bloodthirsty i'll
[ __ ] go into metal gear and start
shooting [ __ ] okay doing what i do
all right
um and then uh i might do some uh
i might do some uh fallout
because every i'm on far harbor i'm not
finished with far harbor yet
um
so
follow me on twitch tom 13 o'clock all
lower case no apostrophe
uh already picked up three people three
more people today on this stream go
ahead and join us over there
i'm not sure and the whole idea behind
this was actually sophie sophie says
what she i was telling her about tomb
raider i said you would love that game
tomb raider and she's why don't you
stream it i'll watch it
so i said okay
i looked into it and i found out that i
had it i had a twitch account for free
because i i got xbox one
and um
so i didn't have to pay anything to get
it
but i think my account was very basic
this doesn't seem to be saving anything
doesn't seem to be saving the streams
and i don't seem to be able to get like
like a super chat okay
but if i get enough people on there i'll
activate it
so uh
and i may even be able to activate
some kind of feature i'll look into it
so where we can talk audio
instead of chat i can read the chat
through my [ __ ]
tablet okay so if you guys are talking
to me i can see it i can talk to you
um
but so far
did a test trial run today and had
[ __ ] five of y'all in there zach was
there and [ __ ] you know we had we had
a good time i only did it for about 45
minutes it knew it was a trial i said
i'll be back soon
so maybe i may maybe on there tomorrow
we'll see probably tomorrow
yeah i mean you could just like stream
all the time yeah
while i'm in here recording video yeah
what not yeah because i i really i get
[ __ ] wrapped up in youtube watching
these other [ __ ] on youtube
which i understand youtube's addictive
but i gotta get off of it
and uh have some
stimulation and i love [ __ ]
i love tomb raider
it's the music and just the the graphics
it's just a very relaxing very relevant
fallout's relaxing too it's like i don't
usually i'm not really into like
watching other people play video games
but
i don't know for some reason fallout and
uh tomb raider yeah i can actually like
watch you play those and those are
actually like pretty entertaining and
like i said they're just relaxing it's
the music it's the vibe
you know i was in tomb raider legend i
was in croft manor and [ __ ]
zach goes man the music is so relaxing i
love this music [ __ ] i could listen
to this all day it's like me too it is
very relaxing
i like it
the tomb raider soundtrack i don't play
it myself anniversary is [ __ ] good
too and and so is so is uh underworld
underworld's really good santa said tom
get red dead redemption yeah yeah yeah i
will i'll get it you'll [ __ ] love it
yeah i think you really really like it
yeah that's a wild west game i'll like
it yeah i'm sure you would it's
expensive though i think it's like 50
bucks
yeah but i mean if you get the older
ones it's probably because that game's
been out like a long time so you can
probably like get some older ones like
for cheap yeah camp guy said men's
restrooms at uh maggiano's little italy
in atlanta have old cheesecake art over
the urinals also an attendant classy
yeah the intended thing is
that's right i don't get it you towels
it weirds me out i was like i don't want
somebody like just that's in there i
mean that's like the worst job well
that's not the worst job ever but it's
one of the worst jobs ever just a gift
is something you give to your friend so
he can make something like one of you
just want to hang out in the bathroom
like for however long your shift is six
hours eight hours and you just gotta
stand there and like listen to people
like pooling and yeah it's not classy
that's not i mean that's 60s and 70s i
don't need somebody to hand me a towel
on it thank you i can see where the
towels are i don't want somebody like
looking at me it's old school old school
60s and 70s like wanting to buck it's
old school 60s and 70s yeah [ __ ] it's
that's not classy it's just creepy yeah
like i said i don't i don't really like
the idea of somebody just like lurking
in the bathroom yeah and then like you
go so they and they're like wanting
money i was like okay get off i can
handle this i'm an adult it's just an
artificial i know
you're in a classy joint you're being
pampered you can't piss and wash your
own goddamn hands
that's what i'm saying
would you like some cologne for the
three i'll put some cologne on here you
know i made it i came in my own cologne
all right i'm wearing a [ __ ]
obsession okay i don't [ __ ] want your
[ __ ] two dollars
all right
well well the weird thing about it is
that like look i don't begrudge people
like you know having a job and making a
living and that's like a job they can
get fined i'm just like i'm not saying
anything about those people yeah but i'm
just saying the whole concept of it is
weird because it's like look if
you all you got to do in the bathroom
you put cologne and towels right there
you just leave them and people will
figure it out
people will figure it out you don't need
somebody to like pick it up and hand it
to you on the slick it may be that
there's somebody in that he's in there
to keep you from [ __ ] shooting dope
in the bathroom i kind of feel like
that's what it is
because okay that kind of the whole
thing about um
you know like retail kind of stuff when
uh when you walk in a store and like
somebody greets you hey sir what's up
today or blah blah blah it's like that's
not because they want you to have a good
shopping experience that's uh that's
low-key telling you hey i'm watching you
don't steal [ __ ]
you know what i mean so i kind of feel
like it's the same principle yeah
xanada's telling me he's gonna start a
new account on there he wants me to play
the old metal gears they're in hd now
all right we'll talk me later i'll get
the old mill i got [ __ ] um two of
them [ __ ] and they're the newer metal
gears they're they're good though i like
them i like them they're all right
even though the metal gear fans didn't
seem to like them
but but you know so far i like them
they're pretty accurate to the way [ __ ]
goes dude it happened in the 80s you can
get some 80s hits you unlock [ __ ]
[ __ ] kids in america and [ __ ] they
had a lot yeah they get [ __ ] on the
radio
and uh yeah they're using old
walkie-talkies and stuff and [ __ ]
which i told you xanada you need to get
you a [ __ ] good
little [ __ ] ham radio or
for for the future you need a little
walkie-talkie for your rig
you're good to have
okay that's almost there all right
now we're going to talk about another
one that's in the uk in england in the
jamaica inn in cornwall
now this place is actually kind of
famous because
daphne du maurier a very famous author
of rebecca and the birds and stuff like
that many of her works have been turned
into alfred hitchcock movies uh matter
of fact
um
her stuff she actually like stayed there
in uh back in the 30s i think and then
she wrote a book
about it like a novel called jamaica in
that was about it and i think alfred
hitchcock made an adaptation of that as
well like back in 1936
so
that kind of like put the place on the
map
but even before that people were talking
about this place being haunted
um i don't remember like it's pretty old
like it's been there for a century or
two at least
but
i feel like the ghost stories have kind
of like
more blossomed after
her book came out and it got like really
famous
so uh the weird thing about it is that
so there's like an old portion of it and
then there was like a newer portion that
was like built in the 1980s and they've
seen ghosts in that part too
so some of the most famous ghosts at
this place
um
is a phantom coach and man i love a good
phantom coach i feel like there's a lot
of places around the world where they
have a phantom coach thing i don't know
why i like that concept so much
but this one has a phantom coach kind of
thing so sometimes people be staying in
there and you hear kind of like uh you
know horse's hooves outside
and you look and there's like there's
nothing there but then like all of a
sudden there's like a ghostly the
[ __ ] coach like from the old days
like back there in the [ __ ] front and
it's like that's that's like really cool
to me i love the full phantom coach kind
of idea so this has one of those um also
there's kind of like um
the people hear
voices like out in the courtyard like
men's voices and a lot of times they're
they've been described as like speaking
a language that people don't recognize
which maybe is old cornish no one's
entirely sure
um but yeah a lot of people have
reported like hearing voices and like
there being nobody there and some people
are like oh maybe this is like all the
smugglers that used to stay there or
whatever
now back in 2004
this particular place was on a
show called most haunted and then i
think like it got a lot more uh interest
after that as well so a lot more like
paranormal investigation team started go
there started going there and stuff like
that
and um the thing about okay so
i think that this place because it's so
famous
from what i gathered i don't know if
this is true or not but from what i
gathered this sounded like
that because this place was so famous
and was kind of famous for being haunted
that it had its own
paranormal investigation team i don't
know if i read that right but it seemed
like that's what they were saying that
they actually employ
a full-time paranormal investigation
team i don't know if that's true or if
they're just kind of like a paranormal
investigation team that's local and they
just kind of like contract them out to
like every now and then come out and do
some investigation to like pump up i
don't know but it sounded it almost
sounded like they kept them on the
payroll because they're always like
investigating [ __ ] like with all their
stuff and they're uh i found like a long
interview with them where they were like
talking about all the stuff they found
in there
so i don't know i don't know if they're
like on the on the payroll full-time
that would be like really weird but yeah
so so what i'm saying now what they've
said was that
um
that there are kind of like a handful of
ghosts that
that have been seen like multiple times
like over the last you know few
decades centuries whatever
and some of them like we're seeing a lot
like in the old days but not so much
anymore so almost like they're kind of
like fading away so there's that
uh the team that
you know investigates there whether
they're full-time or not have basically
said there's like four or five ghosts
that are there kind of like all the time
that are seen like really frequently and
that there's a few other ones that kind
of like pop up every now and again but
the four and the five that's kind of
like the core ghost
team or whatever that's like always
there
um they said one that gets seen a lot
is a guy that's wearing like a us
airman's uniform who will usually like
come through the kitchen door and then
go through the bar and then we'll
disappear
and he's also seen in the stable
sometimes as well like he's been seen
multiple times
and um this isn't that weird because uh
there were a bunch of american troops
stationed in this area uh in cornwall
during the during world war ii and they
went to a lot of pubs and hotels in the
country so it's you know it stands to
reason that maybe there were a few that
hung out there and maybe one of them is
still haunting the place or whatever
now here's the okay now i looked this up
because i was curious
i was reading this article about this
place
and this is what the article says it
says four years ago and whenever this uh
article was written yes so i guess that
was four years ago at around 10 50 p.m
on sunday october 23 2017
cctv camera footage captured the moment
when a wall phone hanging between the
main bar and the utility area in this
place appeared to lift up and then drop
to the floor by itself startling a staff
member whose name was april who was
standing nearby facing the opposite
direction
and about 20 minutes earlier she said
she had heard the
bar door open but nobody entered so i
was like really curious so i was like i
got to see this cctv page so i looked it
up and somebody put it up on youtube
and i will say that they have it from
two angles they actually have it from
the angle where you can see april in the
foreground
and the phone is like way behind her
and
you can see there's like i don't there's
no sound to it but you can kind of like
see
i didn't actually know what i was
looking at at first from like that angle
because it seemed like the phone came
off but all i could see was like this
weird movement like behind her and she
like turned around like what the [ __ ]
like that but then when they showed it
from the other angle it was much much
clearer
i couldn't tell though
if the phone
just
fell off
or
if it flew off it was pretty weird
looking but i don't know if it was like
definitive it could have just been one
of those things where maybe a truck went
by and it just like jogged the phone out
of the
off of the hook you know what i mean
i don't know i was kind of like i i can
get why people thought it was like weird
it was kind of weird looking but i don't
think it was so weird looking that it
was like inexplicable you know what i'm
saying i was gonna like download it and
then like put it on the show but i was
like well i don't know if it's like
impressive enough to really put on there
because
it totally could have been that
something like i said something went by
like a truck or something and it just
like jogged the phone like off because
it could have just gone booped and then
fell off like that what's up david david
june he's just jumping he was the one
that was on my uh on my game stream
today
okay yeah that's guys i was trying to
remember david
but yeah so i was curious enough to like
check the video out and i wasn't
super impressed it's weird but
it's not obviously paranormal like i
could think of a situation where that
might have just happened on its own
but it really seemed to have done the
rounds on youtube of people saying like
oh my god it's pul it's poltergeist
activity which it very well could have
been but i mean it scared her for sure
because she was like what the [ __ ] like
is this phone just like kind of popped
off and then it fell out it's and it's
like a you know it's like an old-school
like land line it had the [ __ ] then
it fell on the floor so
i don't know it was weird but not so
weird that i thought that it was ghostly
you know what i'm saying yeah dave's
asking about the shirt it's canon
studios bro
if you want a canon studios hit me up
all right um
depending on what depending on your size
if it's a large or smaller i can do it
for 20 bucks
larger than large i can deliver it for
about 30.
so
extra large and above 30 bucks super
chat i'll send you one you can only get
it from me exclusive
canon studios the best of the b movies
bro
they made some good movies too yeah they
were good i always associate them with
chuck norris because i feel like they're
superman four but yeah they superman for
[ __ ] all kinds of well now didn't
they make it we we talked about it like
a really good movie the other day that
candidate death wish the surprise yeah
well he'd yeah they did the later death
wish uh didn't they do uh did didn't
canon do um the one with the naked
[ __ ] space vampire chick life force
life force wasn't that canon oh it might
have been i think it might have been
canon toby hooper yeah yeah yeah but he
was under contract to them for a little
bit yeah they might have done invaders
for mars too now i got cannon i got
coral coat
another studio is girlfriend carol coke
yeah
yeah that shirt did come out nice i
think it came out good
i got a muscle shoot version a muscle
shirt version of this i wear it to the
[ __ ] biker barn up there like that
and [ __ ] and those [ __ ] [ __ ] clear
out of the way it says cannon you see
them guns coming they're like yeah okay
bro you got this that's how that [ __ ]
works
that's how that [ __ ] work it's like
[ __ ] out of [ __ ]
don't make me talk [ __ ] okay don't make
me talk why not it's okay all right
it's just
that's all you do is talk i pull up on
my [ __ ] bike and [ __ ] [ __ ] jump
out going to the [ __ ] biker bar
[ __ ] mckenna's shirt on the can of
muscle shirts go to the biker bar today
usually
usually you go on wednesdays they're low
on cash we gotta [ __ ] with you yeah i
was gonna say i'm [ __ ] broke man i'm
trying to economy i can't go anywhere
y'all ain't getting no super
chats i jump out like that
and it's just like [ __ ] terminator
two they're playing bad to the bone and
[ __ ] [ __ ] are backing up
my little five six ass they're [ __ ]
backing up because and he's like i'm
like stand over baby what's up
a
baby
guerrilla ass and everybody's [ __ ]
waving and [ __ ] saying what's up
drinks are appearing i'm i'm i'm famous
there too
i got the shirt are you going to haunt
the oasis after you die
i'm telling you music kind of like the
music i'm trying to tie it back no no
no you'll sit on the bar oh no maybe
you'll haunt the men's room you'll
probably haunt the ladies room i can
only take the oasis in in in [ __ ]
small doses the uh too much country
music being played there that's what i'm
saying it's like you keep trying to like
get me to go there because you told
everybody there about me yeah they want
to meet you all the biker girls i was
just kidding you want to squeeze your
boobs they [ __ ] love you but she she
got some big ass teddies that's not good
just call me charmander yeah yeah they
got some she got some big ass titties i
love her you know either know
[Laughter]
y'all don't even know me
that's not all i am it's just
it's just funny games
i i mean i've thought about it but i'm
just kind of like well
i don't know how long i could like just
hang out there
because i kind of feel like well you
know everybody there yeah and so i'd
mostly just be standing there like
twiddling my thumb no most people
while george thoroughgood played in the
background yeah and you yelled about
testosterone now most people are
drinking
and they're on devices
this is still the modern world and then
there's a jukebox i got the
i got the app for it so i can
don't give me control of the jukebox oh
no man i will i will [ __ ] that [ __ ] up
oh i got sisters of mercy
[ __ ] playing joy division i'm gonna
run all y'all [ __ ] out of here
well i uh [ __ ] i i started playing
all that [ __ ] and i says what y'all
girls want to hear and one girl says
play the cure play boys don't cry that's
like okay i can do that yeah i could do
it yeah old lady [ __ ] wanted and she
was old she was looking like 60. well
yeah that song is old that song's over
but she knew it she because playboy's
don't cry she knew which way i was going
yeah she just wait knows where i was
going doesn't it play boys don't cry so
okay who did all that so the girls like
all the same [ __ ] we like but the dudes
are gonna put [ __ ] country
and sometimes i wonder do the dudes
really like that stuff or do they want i
don't know any better or either they
don't know any better they're like well
maybe if i say that i like the cure or
something like that yeah i think i'm gay
well they're old they're all that's what
i'm saying
but during the day
it's all the bar flies
so they all know each other when i go
there it's all the bar flies so they
know what's going on one dude that
[ __ ] was there he had a stroke he
could barely walk that's my buddy
and he was he's a motorcyclist x biker
but he had a stroke he could barely walk
and he plays nothing but [ __ ] prague
rock
it's got to have perfect toads
parson project
i don't mind that oh yeah you know
you know but i can i could i could i
could rap with him about it that's what
i mean well see i like anybody that is
willing to like dork out oh he's about
to [ __ ] that's what i'm saying that's
cool though i like that i like people
that
are not afraid to like be really really
into something yo he'll dork the [ __ ]
out about [ __ ] david gilmore and
[ __ ]
[ __ ] deep purple and he'll go off
about [ __ ] how good [ __ ] you know
what i mean led zeppelin was and how
good pink floyd was and joe satriani and
all the [ __ ] you know he's into one
of these guitar
master dudes all right
yeah i respect that i'll [ __ ] him up and
i go but i'm gonna play the class she's
don't don't play that
london calling or something i'll play
some [ __ ] crash like come on man
british [ __ ] it's all good and now
[ __ ] you know it's all good yeah
and i'm a motorhead fan i [ __ ] love
lemmy and [ __ ] i'll play lemmy's
[ __ ] biker hits like [ __ ] on
parole and [ __ ] iron horse
everybody loves motorhead from the 70s
i'll go 70s [ __ ] motorhead you know
how can you not let boater head i mean
lemmy was a [ __ ]
moderator he was a [ __ ] ghetto genius
okay he he he getty he was a very wise
man intelligent i like lambie
[ __ ] wear cut off shorts though
crazy as [ __ ] i got a picture of it i
don't understand you know what i mean
but he didn't know any better
he didn't know maybe he just thought his
legs were super sexy and everybody
needed to see them
maybe he was doing a bikini car wash
yeah yeah
he moved to l.a with you know which is
kind of where i came from and he started
hanging out in the viper room they said
that
evidently lemmy was a was a bar fly at
the viper room they couldn't get him out
of there
he was just constantly drunk at the
[ __ ] fire that's okay i understand
that and which is the [ __ ] california
dive but that's where he lived and
that's where all the rockers went see i
don't i know that i know that people
kind of like cast aspersions maybe on
like people that are bar flies and stuff
like that but
some bars and clubs and stuff like that
just have yeah a thing they have like a
a vibe an atmosphere yeah and you just
kind of like well like i said the old
eye bar had that yeah it's like man i
used to just [ __ ] love to just go in
there just the whole atmosphere of the
place was cool you know what i'm talking
about people [ __ ] uh motorhead the
lead singer's name is lemmy kilmister
lemmy was a nickname let me have another
cigarette everybody know that okay no
they're not everybody knows
um
he was british
he was a british kind of biker but they
didn't really have a big
harley scene in in in england that was
more of an american thing and
he really kind of made a better american
than he did
in a brit
he he fit in real well here um
everybody loved him and he would hang
out up at the [ __ ]
viper
and um read books about world war ii
tanks he was a nerd
he loved tanks and bombers and
world war ii history and the machines
he's just a guy he was a guy guy
he like
that was
and
there's a lot of good interviews with
him and phil taylor or filthy animal
taylor and how many times they'd see
each other's girlfriend and they'd laugh
remember how [ __ ] ridiculous and
[ __ ] they were [ __ ] funny that was
hilarious they're very [ __ ] funny the
relationship between those two is like
very very funny to me it's very
entertaining but uh
poor uh lemmy uh died fairly recently a
couple years back with cancer
and he he had a son he didn't know he
had a son but he found out later he had
us an amer an american son
uh he got some groupie pregnant she
wanted to have lemmy's baby and she had
let me have a secret and then the next
thing you know he shows up in his adult
by the way my mom said that you're my
dad i mean tom ross could have a kid out
there for all i know they're out there
they're probably in brazil or korea
that could be out there you know
yeah but who knows one of these days we
might have some random [ __ ]
some random korean that looks like
what
wouldn't that be funny is that that'd be
funny that wouldn't be funny but even
funny was like a korean girl
yeah and i was like what what's up dad
yeah
but now
yeah interesting character [ __ ] real
good catalog
as great as david bowie just it was just
in a different direction it was he was
it was a different genre
rock
real hard rock metal
biker type yeah david june points out
let me die the same year as bowie and
alan rickman it was tough i mean yeah
all of that happening in like [ __ ]
yeah lemmy was sad but it's like david
bowie's dying like [ __ ] me yeah they
were many anglo-american legends died
that year and i don't usually get upset
about celebrities dying because you know
people die and [ __ ] like that but it's
like when david bowie died i was just i
was a mess that was a mess those guys
all live full lives though i know
david june also says tom has admitted me
why not a little tom yeah i don't know
man i keep wondering about so like i
said it's possible right yes it's
possible
you know
there's no way of knowing
i just keep waiting for that we would
have found out by now i mean you would
think yeah what i don't know you never
know you never know
maybe nobody knew about it until
recently we'll see well i think that
dude showed up on lemmy's doorstep he
was in his 30s that's what i'm saying
yeah so and he says by the way
my mom said that you're my dad
the same and they did the test he goes
yeah yeah
yeah and and [ __ ] what was what was
cool about lambie
is that
lemmy and his son became best friends
and uh and it was later on in lemmy's
life
and lemmy said the greatest thing he did
in his life was to make this dude right
there he's pointing his son [ __ ] that
that was that kind of like choked me up
see that because she had that yeah well
and the thing about it is that and i
kind of feel like this happens to a lot
of guys especially guys that are in that
like are rock stars and stuff like that
i think they don't really
understand they don't understand that
creation of life
element that's what i mean so i think it
was probably better that his son i mean
i'm sure it wasn't that great for the
son like when he was younger maybe
because he didn't have a father figure i
don't know like i don't know if she
didn't know that's what i mean so but
maybe it was kind of a thing what that
he found lemmy at the time where lemmy
was older and he was like mature enough
to be like responsible and the guy he
was an adult too so they could kind of
come together
and that's what i mean they were two
actual adults rather than you know this
is like a little kid and he was a fan of
the [ __ ] motorhead he was a motorhead
fan he thought the music was great he
found out that that was his dad
his mom says that was your dad
[ __ ] so i imagine that was quite a
cool reveal
hey can you imagine like if you didn't
know you died oh by the way yeah your
dad's like one of the coolest dudes ever
yeah
not one of the best looking dudes ever
but he was one of the coolest dudes ever
very wise man like i said well good
looking doesn't matter if you're cool
you know what i mean
cool doesn't matter for you if you're
good-looking or not yeah he was [ __ ]
very wise he was interesting looking his
lyrics very very good lyrics
very down-to-earth
very
very american
he said he was
let me i don't want to steal i don't
want to steal british glory but no there
was something very american about but
you have to think too that a lot of
british and british and australian kind
of like punk rockers and people that
were like you know that were into like
old rock music and stuff like that were
really into like american
rockabilly and blues and stuff like that
so you kind of like got that kind of
cross-pollination that's right that's
why yeah
so that i mean you know like i said
that's kind of why you get a like a lot
of the british punk bands and stuff like
that we're really into american well
even billy idol was very american
yeah even though he he was here twice
when he was a little kid too he kind of
grew up here and he went back to england
but uh but it was a good crossover billy
adams of a good cross good mix between
the two yeah
well i told you before like even uh you
know i'm a big fan of anybody that's
been here for a long time i'm a big fan
of like nick cave and like his old band
the birthday party who are australian
and they were they were very american
they were really into elvis like old
blues and like south they were all into
that kind of stuff like the mythology
around like the deep south like all that
kind of swamp losing so what was that so
was uh
so was um
so was [ __ ] billy isle yeah he loved
well a lot of punks were really into
like old like fifties rockabilly elvis
and they were all that kind of stuff
yeah
although they're they're glorifying a
little bit it wasn't that cool
no but i mean filtered through another
culture yeah
like yeah truth behind it was is that
the really cool [ __ ] people of the of
the deep south the really cool white
guys were cool
but they left
yeah they didn't stay in the south in
their lifetime
they would move to other places
because it was it was the south was kind
of limiting well you couldn't yeah you
couldn't really do if you wanted to be
like a rock star you had to go somewhere
else yeah
i mean if you wanted to be like a
country music star you could maybe go to
like [ __ ] even they would have to
leave nashville but nashville and
[ __ ] um you couldn't stay in right
but in atlanta mississippi yeah yeah you
have to go to like atlanta you have to
go to big city because that's just where
that's where the shit's happening
atlanta is the southern version of new
york it's you know it's that's our
version of new york my sister lives
there right
right atlanta was
atlanta was always had cool [ __ ] and it
was big for the south
i've only been in atlanta like one time
in my whole entire life yeah it's a
massive massive place like i said my
sister lives there now she's lived all
over the country but she lives in
atlanta now she's coming down
on
in early october okay and me and her are
gonna go to
disney for their halloween thing okay on
october 3rd okay so i can like see her
she bought me a ticket for my birthday
so
yeah she already bought it just talking
about black star yeah that black star
was video was [ __ ] cool wasn't it
you noticed that [ __ ] in another
video not black star was the other one
david bowie walks backwards into the
closet [ __ ] goes back into the
closet
and his final words was just tell them i
was a closeted heterosexual
i really hope that's true
yeah
okay so
what was i talking about so i was
talking about like this other place now
i okay go to the restaurant you need any
more ice on this yeah probably
i'm gonna actually wait on this story
because i know that you're this is gonna
send you off on another
on another thing because just because of
this guy's name every time it's funny
because i've known tom for so long that
a lot of times like whatever the topic
is when i'm like going through the notes
or whatever of whatever we're gonna talk
about
a lot of time not always because
sometimes he surprises me and he'll just
go off on some tangent that i'm not
expecting
but usually
i'll be like oh you know someone will
have like a funny name or there'll be
like some kind of detail that kind of
like brings up this whole other you know
opens up this whole can of worms and i'm
just kind of like oh that's going to be
like a hole that's going to go off on a
whole tangent
um so then i'll debate like should i
leave that out like should i leave that
fact out because i'm not going to be
able to like get through all the topic
because he's going to go up on a thing
and this was one of those times i was
like talking about like i was writing uh
you know or going through the notes for
this thing and they were talking about
this guy
this guy
like in the history of this place and i
was like
that can't be that guy's real name i'm
like oh my god if i say that out loud
i'm never gonna be able to finish this
show because he's just gonna go off on a
thing so i'm gonna wait i'm gonna wait
and see what happens but like i said i
only have like one or two more cases and
as i said i'm not really all that
concerned whether i get to all of them
or not because
i don't know i kind of figured this show
i was just kind of like whatever i'm
just like being casual about it
so i'm not worried about it
but
i don't know should i say it it's john
[ __ ] that's that's the dude's name
and uh but i'm gonna wait till he comes
back and then i'm gonna tell him what it
is i'm gonna tell him what it is
but uh but yeah so like i said i looked
up this whole this very famous i don't
know if it's very famous but it was like
a cctv thing uh that happened at the
jamaica inn with this whole like
supposed poltergeist activity with the
phone coming off and it's weird but
i don't know like i said it didn't
really see i was just like that could
have just like rattled off of there i'm
not really that impressed by it but okay
whatever it it's weird but it's not that
weird
so uh
whether this team i don't know this
paranormal team
that are investigating this place
apparently full-time i don't know if
they work there full-time or whatever
so the main guy did you forget my dream
okay
he goes in the other room and then he
comes back and he's like i just pushed
it down you forgot about it
yeah
david june said wearing a wig tonight
yeah i'm pretty much always wearing a
wig on the show they're just like
different colors this is my favorite one
but
dick steal yeah so this paranormal team
the guy that runs it is called colin
right
so he's doing he says he's been doing
this investigation in the stable
of the jamaica inn
and he said that he suddenly felt like
his whole body like caught on fire that
like prickly heat all that kind of stuff
and so he had to like run outside
and he said this is one that we put down
to a ghost that we call the blacksmith
now
this blacksmith this is what i was
waiting for
the blacksmith is named
john
[ __ ] what john [ __ ] okay john cop
i'm just i keep saying that okay you're
not going off on it no i ain't [ __ ]
with it
okay
you're disappointing me you're
disappointing me
and that apparently was his road that
wasn't his porn name yeah that was his
real name that's a gay porn
see okay
the thing about porn names is that
i don't like porn names that are too on
the nose you know what i mean yeah is it
john [ __ ] that's too old it's funny but
it's like it's too on the nose yeah you
need a more
you need to go down a little you need to
like
slightly more subtle than that that's
still suggestive
but not as overt as john [ __ ] like i
said that's a little too obvious
i like a little less obvious porn names
but that when you think about him for
five seconds you're like ah okay i see
what you did there john [ __ ] is just
like too much like okay
i don't know it's just too much but that
was apparently the dude's real name
um
have you seen
i took okay i don't know if they still
sell this in american grocery stores but
they used to because i took a picture of
it like a couple years back
they have this it's a soup mix and it
comes in like a little packet and it
just says [ __ ] really big on it
and i was just like walking through the
grocery store like looking for something
else and i just saw that i'm like what
and i took a picture i was like that's a
real thing and it will apparently
because there's a thing in the uk it's i
think it's called cockalicky soup
it doesn't have anything to do with
dicks or anything i don't think but uh
leaky cockalicky yeah leaky [ __ ]
i know it's just i was like there's a
[ __ ] that really is not sound all
that appetizing i have to say there's
this little uh chicano uh goth chick
from california that i subscribed to
we're not subscribed to her friended on
facebook and she posted a photograph one
time of a purse
and on the side of the purse it said i
love [ __ ] for the heart i heart [ __ ] all
right this you just posted that i don't
have any idea what it meant i mean i was
exposed to that i don't think that i
would be going out with a purse like
that yeah yeah yeah you can get trouble
that's what i'm saying yeah i'm not
gonna attempt i don't know exactly what
what the purse talked about but she
posted it
that's just something she saw
[Laughter]
i don't know that's just you know if you
wanna
have that then that's that's fine like
that's cute and everything but it's like
i don't i don't think i would i don't
know
i don't know what it was referring to
i mean it was referring to something
else
i'm just saying in my experience that's
just like that's yeah oh so i don't
think that's a good idea i think
supposed to be cheeky yeah because i
think people are going to get some ideas
yeah she did they're going to be bad she
took a picture and posted it
well i don't know i don't know if that's
what this if that's what this soup mix
was the soup mix was suggesting
something
but the fact that it just said [ __ ]
really big and i was just kind of like
okay
but i guess it was that yeah but it got
my attention so i guess
they they named it correctly
but so this place yeah so this dude his
real name is john [ __ ] right and because
it's in the records and everything and
he was a he was a blacksmith and he
lived there in 1861
and in 1881 the census also showed that
he had a son who he named the same thing
so it was john [ __ ] jr yeah
this is 1881 little [ __ ] they didn't
know what he did
well now okay
how long
has the word [ __ ] been
a youth i don't even think it's not a
euphemism it's a slang term how long has
it been that i don't know
now i'm kind of curious well i'm kind of
curious about like etymology it had to
have not
meant that back then
or maybe it did and everyone was like
like even back then
well because hey when i was in
elementary school yeah
um
i went to school with this girl and her
mom's name was lovely butts
[Laughter]
it was that was her name i can't
remember what the little girl's name was
it was obviously her last name was butts
too but she just had a normal first name
but her mom's name was lovely butts and
i was just kind of like god damn it did
her parents [ __ ] hate her or what
it's bad enough that that's your last
name crazy because she changed that name
god damn it can you imagine
i just can't imagine at least i have
like at least
kind of normal name but jeez ridiculous
and why would why would you do that to
your child no no
if your last name is butts
i would change that
living in an english speaker why would
you want that to be your last name
and then oh let's name them lovely butts
and you know
what the [ __ ] is it honestly i can't
really think of much worse than that
other than like jiggly butts or yeah
jigglypuffs
or something but lovely butts that's
terrible and i don't know why i still
remember that because that was like i
was in elementary school i think or
maybe junior high
so yeah john [ __ ] i got like totally
sidetracked by that
so i don't even remember where i was um
okay oh and there's also like a ghost at
this place who uh puts his little ghost
hand up women's skirts
so there's apparently like a whole
sexual predator there's a whole subgenre
of sexual predator ghosts
that because they're dead they think
they can just get away with like
putting their hands up like living
ladies skirts and laying in bed with
them and pinching their asses and stuff
like that okay look i don't let living
people get away with that there it is
see
oh there you go oh
i see it
yep
okay
i will show you who it is
american military 100 says since the
1700s i'm assuming he means that's when
[ __ ] was okay so
they had to know at this point
that john [ __ ]
was
that's the girl that posted that
i think i'd get in a lot of trouble if i
was her [ __ ] posting that
yeah i i mean i wouldn't if i was me no
i'm not judging i'm just saying
well you couldn't walk around with that
purse poston is okay you just couldn't
walk around with that purse yeah cause i
mean if you're posting it you're like
yeah this [ __ ] was just like it's a
great wig we need to get you one like
that
i used to have one kind of like that but
yeah yeah
she had one that i saw she had a rag in
it or something it looked really good or
like a it was kind of 1700s look in her
1800s looking
there that's the one i'm talking about
look at that wig
with the glasses yeah we got to get you
one like that
yeah jake says kind of like the ghost
from the entity yeah yeah like [ __ ]
rapey ghosts god damn it
and they can get away with it too
they're not even gonna go to jail i
guess that's why they're like hey i
couldn't like [ __ ] do what i wanted
to do when i was alive so now that i'm
dead i can like do all this kind of kind
of stuff
so yeah other than like john [ __ ]
i'm just gonna keep saying that
hilarious i'm gonna get demonetized yeah
that's okay
it's a word
i could be talking about a rooster they
don't know
so uh so yeah
so he was the blacksmith but i think
there's like another ghost there
that's this big dude and kind of like
cranky
and he kind of like runs around the end
too and
i don't know if this is the same guy
that like sticks his hand up women's
skirts though
and one of the ladies that's on the um
paranormal team
she says that this one particular ghost
the big uh cranky one he said uh you
know he was probably the ghost of um
somebody that was there like around the
1750s
and as such he's not real he's not a big
fan of these uh mouthy modern women
so they talk back
right they've talked back too much yeah
and she says uh you know
as a man of that period this is what
she's saying he doesn't seem to like
modern strong women in those days in
those times women would have been
subservient and without the rights they
have now asking if there's a woman he
likes i've gone around the room and
touched each one on the shoulder and
when i reach one that's a bit more buxom
meaning they have like big titties
then the equipment they have will she
says it goes mental so he's like oh i
like that one because she has the
biggest titties yeah but yeah he said he
doesn't really like ones that are like
he was a booboologist yeah he was also a
blueball she's a ghost bibologist
that's [ __ ] hilarious that's it but
you know i don't really think that like
these ghosts like really exist or
anything but it's like it's kind of
depressing to me it's like you're just
such a douche in real life and it's like
then you just continue your douchery
like into the ghost world like you
didn't learn anything or
that's pretty that's pretty grim
i'm just saying
now this
[ __ ] the bubologist ghost
he was actually first of the poopologist
that's what i'm calling him
uh he was actually first reported in
1911
and uh some people have seen him too
they said that one of the things that he
does he's wearing like the old-fashioned
duds and everything and he's usually
like sitting or leaning on the front
wall like in front of the place
and they said that a lot of times people
will drive by there and think it's a
dude and they'll like hey be like hey
bro or what's up and he just like kind
of sits there and doesn't say anything
or doesn't look at them and then he
disappears so a lot of people have seen
him like just sitting on the outside
outside wall
and uh they said they've seen the same
guy like sitting in the bar area
and he sits there so often that the
table that he sits at is called jack's
table because so i guess that's his
place now and uh so he'll just like kind
of sit there and like stare at people
and then just disappear which is a
little bit uh creepy
okay uh so
we don't know okay so i don't know if
this is the same ghost or not but they
said that one thing that happened there
like a long time ago
there was a guy and he comes into the
bar and he's drinking his ale or
whatever he was like not from there so
they didn't really know who he was
and somebody called him outside i don't
know why like i don't know if he was
just like hey i don't like the look of
your face i'm just gonna like kick it in
or whatever but he just like gets
brought out there
so he leaves like half his beer he's
just like okay i'm coming out there so
he goes outside
and then the next morning they found him
dead out on the moor like somebody had
called him out there and then they
killed his ass
now they don't really know who killed
him though but they just like found his
body on the moor
and this guy has is apparently still
haunting the police um
you know people have heard like
footsteps going up and then and
the the story kind of rose up that it's
like well his beer was only half
finished so maybe he's like keeps coming
back to the bar to like finish his drink
but he never can because he's dead
so there's that kind of thing
so that might be like the guy that
they're seeing i don't know there's also
another girl another ghost in there it's
like a little girl named hannah
and uh there's this was kind of cool
like one person that was staying there
said they were staying in one room of
the place room five and they woke up and
they saw a little girl like wet
footprints
on the carpet that was going across to
the kind of the wardrobe or the little
kind of like a dresser or whatever where
the bathroom used to be there's not a
bathroom there anymore but it used to be
one there and so there was little wet
footprints like little kid footprints
and uh also people that have stayed in
that room said they've heard like
footsteps running around the bedroom at
night
and people have also seen like woken up
in the middle of the night and seen like
a little girl like standing by the side
of their bed
and some people have said that they that
she touched their legs as well
so there's that
um and hannah is apparently so famous
that people have started writing her
letters and sending her toys and they
put the toys in the place and the toys
like move around on their own sometimes
so they think she's probably like a
victorian era like the ones that have
seen her she looked like she's dressed
and like has hair from that time period
so that's what they think that is and
they said that they've heard her like uh
laughing in the gift shop and she's also
like throwing around uh books
and pulling people's hair and stuff like
that so there's that and there's also
kind of like babies crying at the end
that kind of crap
so do you want to like wrap it up or you
go ahead and wrap it up you hungry i
guess so yeah i mean we just want some
noodles want some ramen noodles yeah
that sounds good you do that or pizza
yeah we had like a little bit of pizza
earlier i made this [ __ ] on [ __ ] naan
bread it was cheap cheater pizza but it
came out good cheater pizza yeah put it
on non-bread did it in the damn airframe
airfryer
yeah
you have to know how to do it right but
i got a good airfryer it's like a little
mini oven
but if you want noodles i can make us
some noodles got any eggs put in there
yeah i got eggs
i like waffles you gotta cut me loose
right now and i'll start boiling the
eggs
you gotta cut me please got me loose i
mean i was gonna do like i said i had a
couple more but i was kind of like we've
got ben we've been going for probably
three hours probably three and a half
hours okay yeah we can shut it down hey
thank you very much people [ __ ]
thanks for [ __ ] showing up thank you
for the super chats if you want to drop
jenny another super chat before we check
out [ __ ] that'd be great too because
you know she worked very hard on this
show
uh but if not i'm gonna [ __ ] split
i'm gonna start
cooking up some food for me and jenny
and uh i will see you guys probably
tomorrow huh not tomorrow friday friday
friday night for the side track [ __ ]
okay if you want to close it out jenny
go ahead and close it out all right so
we'll be back sorry i didn't get to
everything but like i said i
told you ahead of time that i probably
wasn't gonna get to everything because i
knew that we were gonna go off on a
bunch of tangents and since we've
already been going for three and a half
hours and i'm getting kind of tired to
be honest with you and kind of hungry so
uh we'll be back on we're gonna take
tomorrow off and then we'll be back on
friday for the side track show so
hopefully you guys i mean like this
wasn't a sidetrack show but you know how
we do so come back on friday
and we'll do the sidetrack show it'll be
super fun
and uh that'll do it for this episode we
will see you guys on the next one
bye